okay
foreign
foreign
laughs
darling
me
[Music]
I have with me David packman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and TV program The
David packman show and I wanted to talk
to David Pacman he is a beta male
David Patman is
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional they are mentally off they
have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but the whole
world will adjust you well we got it
that's a lot that's a lot we would
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male dog but another doesn't because
he's a logical thinking and they're
controlled by the darkness of David
Pac-Man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're not here to communicate I really
appreciate you coming on I'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you we're not communicating you're
acting like that because you're asking
bizarre questions
and you wasting my time goodbye
[Music]
let him know
[Music]
that's a progressive folk all men who
are progressive on males who are
progressive
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets
and shelves
10 times 15 times
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation a big massive dumps
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
the United States thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
this is
just expenses
look at that
[Music]
this is
mangoes
[Music]
I love mangoes too
now that we
that we buy these regime
my bag of mangoes now cost eleven
dollars and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal bag
of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
[Music]
bring my mango
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified
[Applause]
[Music]
McDonald's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey welcome everybody you guys are not
going to believe the mango story I have
for you I I've been laughing all weekend
waiting to tell you guys this story wait
what day is it Saturday well anyway for
a few days during the week this happened
during the week I've been laughing for
days waiting to tell you guys this story
We the mango jokes we didn't even create
the mango jokes it came from diamond and
silk in the song the other day I'm at
Whole Foods okay uh you know getting 12
seaweed and um I'm in the checkout with
my girlfriend and no joke she says to me
sir
can can you grab some mango while I stay
in line get some of the pre-sliced mango
so I run over to the mango section you
know the pre-cut fruit section and I'm
there and I'm looking and I'm not I'm
just I'm not seeing the mango
and all of a sudden a Whole Foods worker
comes over with a cart where they have
all their he's gonna stock the
pre-sliced fruit and I look at him and
he goes David Pacman I love your show
and I go oh thank you do you have mango
are you the mango guy and he goes I
normally am but we're completely out of
mango there's not a mango to be had in
this entire store and I just I it after
everything on the show with the mango
song The you know the I'm I'm
desperately looking for mango and the
mango guy recognizes me but they don't
have any mango that day uh an incredible
story an historic story
in fact I would say quite an anecdote uh
welcome everybody we are standing by for
president Donald Trump then he went
Donald Trump yeah Donald Trump one of
the few presidents who has ever gotten
his own name wrong in fact I'm expecting
um an incredibly
disgusting diabolical
delusional and dastardly dilapidated
diatribe from Donald Trump tonight
um and uh that's in about an hour and
I'm so glad to have everybody here I
have so much content for you guys today
because it's been a couple of days since
I streamed we're gonna give away some
free memberships I have 508 membership
requests uh you can request one at uh
davidpackman.com free membership so
we've got that going we're gonna play
Deepak Chopra or Jordan Peterson I've
got some new uh elements of that for you
guys
um we're gonna look at Super chats I
mean it's it's really wild cribly
sending in a 20 Super Chat saying only
woot that's cool I'll take it
I'll take it
um
I don't even know where to start quite
frankly let me just thank people who
have supported us already a green man as
well as Cody and skittlestu has gifted
two subs small fuzzy Moss is demanding
the mangoes come back down AJ Scorpia
has re-upped so that already puts us at
five I am determined I am determined
today to get us to 100 okay and in so in
in that goal
website memberships count as one twitch
subscriptions count as one and patreon
pledges count as two
just just saying thanks to Pepper love
for gifting a twitch Prime subscription
very very much appreciate that Jay
Harper says David sir what's your
powerful position on dried mango
I like it but it's addicting here's my
perspective on dried fruit I love it but
don't give me any extra sugar if I see a
grain of of additional added sugar on my
dried fruit I'm putting it directly into
the trash and by that I mean I'm just
not buying it I wouldn't actually throw
food out but I want it's got enough
sugar
it's got enough sugar guys we don't need
extra sugar
uh on dried uh dried fruit the you know
and the the sad thing about it is and
it's really a shame
with a dried cranberry
it's essentially inedible without added
sugar it's unfortunate
it's unfortunate because the the
cranberry is so tart
um that I've never been able to even
find dried cranberries without added
sugar It seems impossible it seems like
an impossible uh
and if we don't stop them they'll do it
again in 2024 that's the important thing
about cranberries
thanks to Kathy for the 20 Super Chat
Laura says with love from Ontario Canada
welcome welcome welcome welcome it's so
great to see you here I want to say
thanks to Christopher Elliott who just
signed up on my website and his new
member number seven today thank you
you're the man yes we still have uh yeah
so when we we have a beautiful event
actually I have two events coming up to
tell you guys about
uh let me get my calendar out here since
it is April on Tuesday
April 19th we will be doing the next
David packman show Town Hall it will be
a global town hall open to everybody and
it will stream live only on the Pac-Man
Live Channel That's April 19th Tuesday
that's how I pronounce it now Tuesday
April 19th
on the other hand when we reach 100
000 twitch followers we will be doing a
multi-hour twitch exclusive Town Hall
only only
televised you know broadcast on Twitch
so that's that 100 000 twitch followers
so a lot to look forward to
uh people uh awaiting the demise of the
show will sadly have to wait a little
bit longer because things are very much
on the up and up thanks to Badness
holler back and the diseased as well as
an anonymous gifter for gifting five
five plus three is eight eight plus
seven five carry the one puts us at 15
for the evening uh I also want to say
thank you to Hillary Lee Hillary has
just gifted a subscription on my website
that's number 16 and as a result one of
our viewers named tinash mangozo
wow the word mango is in the last name
that's incredible Tinashe mangozo is the
recipient of the first gifted
subscription we added a new box uh
everything is box based on our website
and so when you go through the sign up
process you'll see there's a box here is
this a gift if you check the box
um
and leave blank It'll ask you do you
want to send it to someone in particular
if you leave it blank you're basically
sending it to me and then I can give it
to someone so Hillary Lee just gifted uh
tinash mangozo a subscription and right
now
508 people are waiting for free
subscriptions you can add your name to
the list that davidpackman.com free
membership we have a bit of a supply
demand issue right now so right now we I
have zero memberships left to gift but
509 people waiting so um
oh Neil dunworth and Kevin Combs have
just gifted two more that puts us at 18.
which means that now
here we go now Katie Anthony gets a free
subscription and Sarah Stidham Sarah
Stidham gets a free subscription so we
have a massive uh I guess we would call
it we have membership debt of for lack
of a better term
for lack of a better term okay uh do you
guys want to play um one round of uh
Deepak Chopra versus Jordan Peterson
um I've got it ready to go my colleague
John has very very uh generously put
together a few more rounds of it for us
uh let's let's play Let's Play here's
the game the game is my argument is that
Jordan Peterson's uh what would we call
them words salads I guess I believe
Jordan Peterson's word salads are often
as nonsensical and incoherent as Deepak
chopras okay so we get a quote and we
have to guess who's quote who said it
okay so moderators on Twitch please help
me out I'll set up the poll on YouTube
the quote is the quote is I think
Consciousness is non-local consciousness
is a superposition of possibilities okay
so I will I will put here who said it
Deepak Chopra or Jordan Peterson and we
will go live with that on YouTube
um
and let's see if I can set up the poll
on Twitch who said it
Deepak Chopra Jordan Peterson
and let's start it okay and then we will
look at the answer right now on YouTube
it's 60 40 60 believe this is a Deepak
Chopra quote but it is closing in with
Jordan Peterson on Twitch it's 50 50
right now twitch oh no twitch is also
leaning Deepak Chopra
I think Consciousness is non-local
consciousness is a superposition of
possibilities
who said it Jordan Peterson or Deepak
Chopra Let's test ourselves and our
ability to identify the oranges of
pseudoscience and sort of word salads
take a look at the oranges of the
investigation over on YouTube it is
still 60 40 Deepak about 65-35 okay so
I'm gonna call it I'm going to end the
poll let's see who said it
I think Consciousness is non-local I'm
sorry I think Consciousness is non-local
conscious Consciousness yeah you know
I've never really run across a
definition of Consciousness that I
understood okay so it is it is the fact
Oprah Making the brilliant point that
Consciousness is non-local uh it is long
distance long distance all right you
guys want to do one more that's the gist
of the game do we want to do one more
um
my chair is actually experiencing some
quantum entanglement right now and I I
may have to replace it a little bit
later
we'll do one more okay let's do one more
I want to you know save some oh boy look
at this I'm okay there is a subjectivity
which is independent of objects there is
a subjectivity which is subjectivity of
itself when you're looking at the brain
for consciousness
uh you're not looking at Consciousness
you're looking at synaptic filings in
fact it is your Consciousness that is
looking at those synaptic filings okay
let's let's do another poll
who said it Deepak Chopra Jordan
Peterson and it is live on YouTube
and let's see if I can end this poll
uh oh man I can't so I guess we're not
going to be able to do it on Twitch
because I like somehow can't end the
poll early
so it sounds very chopra-like but I'm
wondering if John included this one
because that's the deceptive part and
it's actually Jordan Peterson
subjectivity independent of objects
subjectivity subjectivity of itself
you're not looking at Consciousness
you're looking at synaptic filings
our synaptic filings like nail filings
like nail trimmings of sorts
all right 74 on YouTube believe that
this is Jordan Peterson let's take a
look let's take a look at who said it
you just said that Consciousness and
mind are I didn't say Consciousness in
mind I said mind is a product of
Consciousness the subjectivity is
independent of the objectivity of the
brain there is a subjectivity which is
independent of objects whether it's
subjectivity which is subjectivity of
itself when you're looking at the brain
for Consciousness you're not looking at
Consciousness you're looking at synaptic
firings in fact it is your Consciousness
that is looking oh see I think he said
synaptic firings not filings that's it's
a it's an understandable mistake because
it is quite a word salad endosynaptic
firings okay so um all right so that one
was Deepak Chopra uh you know D I
believe that Deepak Chopra has
essentially made his career
oh hold on we have Pillow yeah
yeah all right we're gonna flip the
camera really quickly
it's pillow look at this
[Music]
hello Michigan yeah anyway Deepak Chopra
has has a career based on the fact that
other people don't know what the hell
he's saying and the other people instead
of going wow he must not really be
saying anything they go he must be so
smart I can't even understand what he's
saying I should really give him money
that's like that's that's what it is now
as you guys know Mike pillow is filing a
big lawsuit against all machines we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines and if that is the case if that
is the case this broadcast will soon be
shut down
um I have actually put my uh Breville
espresso machine into the witness
protection program in advance of this uh
major major lawsuit coming against all
machines from Mike pillow okay thank you
to your billion Harry Rhino JP de Beast
hersafat
Phoebe USA Pollux deba bone Master J
uh
uh that is eight twitch Prime
subscriptions which I absolutely love I
absolutely love over on the website I
want to say thank you to Michelle K's
for signing up as well as Jim Murray new
members 27 and 28 and an extra special
thank you to Rebecca gretzinger
Seneca Berg and Haley Brady they have
each generously gifted a subscription on
my website which means that Jesse
gingras gets a free membership because
Jesse asked for one Brian Lee gets a
free membership and Sean Dowler gets a
free membership if you want a free
membership to my website it's just about
asking for it guys you go to
davidpackman.com free membership put in
your info you'll be added to the list
and we're just going in order
it's first come first served here let's
look at a few other super chats here
Aloha from Kawaii beautiful
sir did you see me Jimmy Kimmel's bit on
pillows machine class action lawsuit I
haven't I should look for it
Christopher says thanks so much David
for keeping us informed and battling
right wing Insanity well thank you
Christopher for being here
is it just me or does pillow look like
Paul Bearer The Undertaker's earn carry
guy I'm not familiar with who that is
Cyrus or saru says David why do people
keep going to Trump rallies nothing but
the same grievance is on repeat how are
they not bored yet well they do get
bored typically the attendees do get
bored during the rally
um and we'll probably see that happen a
little bit later today I anticipate
significant levels of boredom let's look
at some clips from the event I think you
guys are going to like these
Ron philipkowski is a great person to
follow on Twitch on Twitter rather
um let's look at some of these clips
here
uh uh there I don't want to look at all
of these but
uh hold on a second oh here we go new
Trump attorney and former oan's talking
person Christina Bob says people will go
to a jail for election fraud if diperno
wins out in how
I believe is running for AG in Michigan
that's the whole point of the rally I
guess those criminal prosecutions you
get an attorney general in Michigan like
Matt diperno who's you know hell-bent on
Prosecuting and making sure that people
pay for what they did and I think we'll
see those prosecutions and I think by 24
which is also a very important election
I think we'll see our elections pretty
close to being cleaned up and they're
going to clean them up for us guys it's
all going to be clean really really soon
here's a guide a trump rally running for
school board on a no CRT
it's hard to really even call it a
platform but I don't know
CRT no CRT
matter of fact
two if
it's chromosomes you are a what
female yeah yeah the crowd doesn't know
the crowd has no idea whether XX is male
or female this is the last crowd that's
going to be able to shout out answers on
biology
very very stupid idea to ask these
people about chromosomes
they don't know it they don't know it
even got facts I got recordings of them
trying to get CRT in our district so if
anyone that lives in Southgate make sure
you keep that in note I will change keep
it in note guys in note I said and I
will make sure our district thrives and
what it's been for the past decade this
message is not paid by him thank you
very much wow good luck on your election
what an American
what an American globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike Obama Trudeau mccrone and the
rest of these Zio beasts yeah
um
This Woman's wearing a shirt that says
hate cops the next time you need help
call a crackhead Trump 2024. hmm
women at a trump rally asked what
response she gets when people find out
she loves Trump oh this I have to hear
feedback that you get from reporter
[Music]
I'm like you said no and it's it's
really mind-blowing because everything
that he said he's turned out to be right
time and time again yeah like for
example Trump said that if Biden became
president people would be flushing
toilets 10 to 15 times the only person
doing that is Trump
um this woman started crying because of
how much Trump loves the country
children and we need we need you trump
our country is going to [ __ ] oh my God
this is what we need you Trump
we need you Trump why this is why we do
this with people like you because we
know how important it is for we know we
love this country and we know exactly
what Trump would do for God this country
is so messed up guys it's so depressing
it's so depressing
this country is so messed up
look at the people that live here
they're crying because they want Trump
to be president so bad for this country
for you and I said God bless you I I we
really want you too and Trump I love you
you're my man you're you're coming back
the cabal the Deep state
not this country the cabal
dear God we are screwed as a country
oh man it's like do we need to all go to
Red states to make them blue or do we
need to get the hell out and just go to
Blue states where things are more sane I
I don't I don't I just don't know
I don't know do we need to apply light
and heat to cure apply light and heat to
cure yeah
it's it's really bad really bad thanks
to Zig Maestra Napa skip dog and Solomon
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 34. I also want to say
thank you to Anne Reagan
and Samantha silvurn for signing up at
joinpakman.com today's coupon code on
our website is Obama Obama at any Trump
speech it's possible that he will utter
that famous word remember this guys this
is the origins of it here we go
in Trump trouble remember that
frog voted against the border wall oh
that's a good thing to him he voted
against Kate's law and he voted for
Obama okay so that's where it comes from
and we may hear it tonight we may hear
it's always possible that it'll come out
of uh
yeah you know what I at this point
Stephen Kenneth that oh well I actually
I can't even say then I don't even want
to I don't want to get kicked off of
twitch I'm not even going to say this
person's name there's a streamer who is
currently banned from twitch that has
completely stolen Obama Obama from us
completely stolen Obama from us and uh
it's I I'm considering I'm just
considering myself flattered uh Molina
stole it as well they all stole it it's
fine it's it and you know uh
memetic theft or meme jacking as it's
known among the kids
um it's the it's the sincerest form of
flattery it really is it really is so
I'm fine with it
thanks to Sling Blade and camera tages
for the twitch Prime subscriptions uh
putting us at uh putting us at 40.
which I very much appreciate Candace
says via Super Chat huge fan of you
mangos and Tuesday thank you Candace
appreciate that watching a trump rally I
don't know whether to laugh or cry well
we just saw a woman that was crying
if you want the Jimmy Kimmel bit search
for my pillows Mike wacky new lawsuit on
YouTube start the clip at 9 40. well I
always like to preview stuff in general
when I can before showing it on stream
so I will check it out I will check that
out
um come on in everybody oh people want
to hear a little bit from what pillows
sing speech it's got 1.2 million
downloads this is what went on inside
it's the manipulation of the vote it's
everything that we knew that they were
hiding so it's out there now now you
know it's like you have this guy here's
the gun okay now what are we gonna do
about it well what we're doing is I'm
going I have a team of lawyers going to
every state we're doing seven of them
first next week we're doing preliminary
injunctions to get rid of the machines
once and for all under U.S code 1983
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines you know the whole
thing about us code 1983
it's so it has nothing to do with voting
machines it's about people can't have
the rights their fundamental rights
restricted and what pillow is arguing is
that when voting machines are used
people's fundamental rights are being
restricted but they're not it's just
people are just voting using machines
that's all and the Jews that have the
people's back you know not just for you
God bless all right well
we'll take it
wow these are some of the worst people
huh yeah I think you better ask the
other guy
I think if it's up to him all right all
right you guys I'll let you get to your
photos but Mike thank you so much God
bless Mike Lindell are you kidding me
thank you so much
[Applause]
um he gave me a cell pillow did and said
I can text him anytime for whatever you
know if I ever need anything it's like
I'm like what could I possibly need even
if I were to even if I wanted pillows
I'm not going to him
um okay so that's going on Newsmax is
also covering the event so we are
standing by for that and it is it is
such an insane day okay I promise this
and as you guys know when I make a
promise
my word is my bond to the audience I
promised you David Pacman show related
slap memes I said send them in send them
in we'll debut all of them the best ones
on the Trump rally stream on Saturday
would this be an appropriate time to
introduce into evidence 15 different
slap memes related to the show would it
would that be is that okay if I were to
introduce those now into evidence
yes people seem to want it
thanks to Sir Digby chicken caesar for
the twitch Prime subscription remember
also today patreon pledges count as two
and they will rapidly uh rocket us
towards
um towards 100
we want the memes okay let's do it
here's the memes so I received about 50
I picked what I believe to be the best
15. I know not everybody will disagree
oh not everybody will agree rather
um but it is going to be
uh let's see what's going on here
actually I'm gonna need a second to get
this set up so let's listen to this just
while I set this up hold on hi everyone
and welcome back to right side
broadcasting network I'm your host Liz
Willis our other very important host for
this evening Brian Glenn is behind that
stage right now doing an interview with
the one and only Donald J Trump 45th
president of the year so we're gonna
have that interview for you here in just
a few minutes in the meantime it's just
me but I'm excited to be here and I'm
excited to hear what Brian has to say
with his words with the present here
shortly I want to thank you guys for
tuning in we have
about 40 minutes until president Trump
is okay all right let's go to the slap
memes let's go to the slap memes here
they are here are the ones that I think
are the funniest ones so here is uh I
guess someone's asking what is the
definition of and then I slapped Chris
Rock that's this that's this one
okay
that's not bad that's not bad
um let's go to the next one mute your
Discord yeah that's a regular problem
that's a regular problem that we have on
the phone so that's not bad
that's a permaband
um and Chris Rock is the microphone now
just as a reminder guys we're against
violence I think what Will Smith did is
disgusting he's completely wrong uh
Chris Rock said words and then Will
Smith slapped him it's completely
inappropriate he should have been
immediately asked to leave etc etc we're
also just doing some entertainment so
everybody relax I'm not defending
anything that Will Smith did okay just
every Everybody calmed down uh
okay let's and these are kind of weird
here we go all right now we're going to
the next one
David Pacman's producer are you kidding
me with more member discounts yeah the
team is upset you know when I discount
membership so much they don't like it
but I'm Gonna Keep discounting
memberships
David's starting his stream gets slapped
by David's audio that happens sometimes
sometimes we do have pretty big issues
that's true that's fair
all right when someone tells you to turn
off Pac-Man and watch Sam Cedar oh boy
that is that is a pretty serious shot
across the bow
that's aggressive
sends email
okay navigate to davidpackman.com free
membership to sign up for a free
membership sends email yeah so last week
when we debuted this membership request
thing I said very specifically do not
email me do not email me the only way to
ask for a free membership is to fill out
the form at davidpackman.com free
membership and five or six people
emailed and they said could it could you
put me on the list it's like no I can't
I'm sorry
I can't do that
um let's see what else we got here
how we feel when Pac-Man's hair is
undone
okay
not bad
the liberal War on Christmas slaps
Chinese tchotchkes
yeah
that one's pretty D that that's like a
pretty inside thing I don't know if
people even remember that whole thing
nuclear is slapping nuclear that I like
I am partial to nuclear
nuclear nuclear I like this one this is
a good one
um a hearty running lathe slaps David's
patience yeah when people run heavy
equipment during phone calls I don't
like it I don't like it
oh this one's more involved
look at my cool set everyone and then
Sam Cedar slaps me and then I say but
you literally told me how to build it
and then Sam Cedar yells from the crowd
with Emma next to him keep my set out of
your effing show that's pretty good
that's pretty good actually this may be
the best one
I have no idea who made any of these
yeah I don't I don't even have the I we
just put them into a thing I don't even
I don't know I'm not even sure but
that's a very good one
uh claiming mangoes under the Biden
regime are 11.99 a bag it gets slapped
by mangoes now under the Biden regime or
five for five bucks very true
accurate as well
they just walk up and say Sir oh and you
combine Sir with a slap that's not a bad
idea actually sir sure I like that
um and then I think I've got one more
bagged mango prices slap diamond and
silk and the Wisconsin crowd all right
that's pretty good all right so pretty
good this one's good this one's really
good and I also think this one's
excellent these might be my top three
but they're also the only three I
remember
um excellent work everybody excellent
work in all seriousness really really
nice job and some nice uh nice
submissions there very very nice
submissions
thank you to Nick Lovin
memejacking is a victimless crime says
Nick with his twitch Prime subscription
number 42. okay other super chats uh
let's see if I've got new ones thanks
Julie for the twenty dollars sir can you
play the clip from Monday's stream with
the audio problems it's hysterical yeah
let me see if I can find it
uh let me see here
audio there were some pretty big audio
problems
if you missed it here's what happened a
couple of streams ago
it was pretty brutal
oh I'm hearing myself coming back that's
weird
are you guys hearing me twice every time
you're not
okay let's try now
okay I think let's try now no I still
didn't I'm still hearing myself okay
okay let's try now no I still didn't I'm
still hearing myself okay okay let's try
now no I still didn't I'm still hearing
myself okay okay let's try now no I
still didn't I'm still hearing myself
okay okay let's try now no I still
didn't I'm still hearing myself okay
okay
Australia
genuinely don't know where that's coming
from
um
[Music]
okay I think that's the gist of it I
don't know that I need to keep going
with it but that it was a big big
technical issue on uh that first that
first stream last week so we figured it
out is the important Point
um okay very very good
uh let's see what else I've got here not
really nothing else uh over there
um okay here's a couple other Clips I
had for you the opening prayer at
today's Trump rally started with the
belief that Trump was the current
president
work together so we pray Father in
heaven we firmly believe that Donald J
Trump is the current and true president
of the United States you have raised him
up for this season of time to be used to
be part in Saving a nation look at this
woman back here
the whole
you guys see that for a prayer that
Trump is actually the real president
physical spiritual attacks and may his
voice stir the people to righteous
action to bring golly men and women into
elected office in Michigan and across
America we declare he will be back in
office soon very soon in Jesus name amen
this is this is sick
this is these people are crazy
this is crazy this is uh it's it's
mental illness and we're not we're not
it's not a joke guys it's a delusion
this is these are delusions
this is sick we pray we pray the fraud
in a 2020 election will continue to be
exposed and the election decertified in
Michigan the Battleground state in our
nation in Jesus name
right
right
so um I mean that's it's very very sick
it's very very sick
um they're playing Elton John
[Music]
dear God it's it's really really
freaking messed up
a lot of a lot of horrible things going
on
um that Tech difficulty needs to be
mixed yeah if anybody wants to do a
serious remix with my audio problems
from the other day there's a post on the
subreddit with that entire video that I
played which you can pull down and it
could definitely be uh it could
definitely be used I'm hoping for
technical difficulties today during the
um during the rally because it's so
irritating to Trump when there's Tech
trouble
and our incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing the
bike
exactly exactly okay
um very very good so we've taken care of
that
Denver says the guy praying for Trump to
still be president looks weirdly like
Bill Clinton could it be him no no no no
that was a Christian Pastor that was not
that was not the former President Bill
Clinton
uh thank you to
katulu's quach I guess
um for the twitch Prime subscription you
were number 43 43.
Juan says not a joke all right
Adrian sends a 10 super chat with no
message
mysterious no message whatsoever that's
that's pretty serious stuff uh let's see
what's going on here in the in in the
venue I think it's just because I'm not
censored I'm not a shadow band so
whatever they're algorithms are doing I
like it you guys if you haven't already
go download getter that's g-e-t-ttr
they've got the app you can do it on a
desktop and make sure you follow at RSB
Network when you do so I'll be on there
I like to check it as much as I can
um and I interact with the RSV and
comments as well through my
um unfortunately we have anti-Semitism
uh coming through via Super Chat
um you are banned I hope that was worth
wasting five dollars on
uh but pretty pretty ugly stuff that
people will do
uh uh yeah one thing I do want to
mention there's there's actually in all
seriousness guys we are having an issue
with the Trump streams because what's
going on is
apparently like
I I don't really know unlike some of
these other people I don't really know
too much about the YouTube algorithm and
exactly how it works but pretty clearly
the channel our channel is now big
enough that
the the stream is clearly being promoted
just to random people who aren't our
subscribers and I guess a bunch of them
are Trump supporters just looking to
watch the rally and so what happens is
Trump supporters who have no idea who I
am they'll end up watching my stream
and then they'll notice that I don't
like Trump I think Trump's a do you know
a doofus and they will go completely
crazy uh they start spamming anti some
they very quickly they have no idea who
I am but very quickly figure out that
I'm Jewish and they'll start spamming
the chat with um anti-Semitism for a
week anytime we do one of these streams
for a week I I will just get bombarded
with all sorts of uh hate messages of
different kinds from people who are like
you should just be quiet during the
rally well no go you go watch it
somewhere else like Trump is a genius
and you don't understand his genius and
all the just go somewhere else you know
you don't have to watch it here
uh fortunately this all this stuff is is
optional Firestar says greetings from
the Netherlands with a 20 Euro Super
Chat those Euros are strong
those Euros are strong these days I
appreciate that very very much
um
welcome to high Gull who just got a
twitch Prime subscription very very much
appreciate that
let's see what else we've got
uh
well some voicemails I'll do a couple
voicemails yeah I'm not gonna go crazy
with the voicemails today
but let's just take a look at some of
the things we have
um
let's see
hey David
Dave in California
you won't believe this
but Madison Hawthorne put out a
statement regarding the orgies
and the drug use
that he saw
or the or do you see one okay Dave from
from California we love him but his
voicemails are notoriously so slow I
have uh oh we may have a new caller to
debut right now we have a caller who
this morning left one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
Seventeen eighteen nineteen voicemails
oh boy this is a new caller they're from
country code 86 let's see what country
that is oh that's China
China do I dare listen to this
oh man
let's listen
hi David
I used to watch the show a lot my name
is ioni my name is ioni Talmadge
and I need help oh
I am here I'm an American citizen
and I am here
and China with my daughter uh-oh as an
English teacher and I am trying to kill
him uh oh
um
with my child
why can't she leave I haven't explained
this situation
to my company
that I'm exhausted from teaching
I'm exhausted
because the job is is not
it does not sustain both it is not able
to sustain my child or me hmm
so
there's 20 voicemails and they all go
the full three minutes
uh
uh let's look let's listen to the second
one
I'm An American in a foreign country
here in China as a single mom
and so if I act out or show any inkling
of of
civil Behavior
I will be detained hmm
third voicemail
so
they've locked out team they blocked off
FEMA I knew that when I came well now
they've blocked off Yahoo so uh oh
um all right so then like an hour later
she was still calling work this is the
first listen for all of us I don't I
don't know anything about this
I don't know anything about this
I have done many jobs I've been many
things but I have always been to the
best of my ability me
I don't know what else to do
hmm
should I say the American Anthem was
saying or say the American you know
stereotypical chant I am an American
you can't do this to me
all right I'm gonna get away from this
because there's a bunch of different
things going on there's I'm gonna have
to just step away from that there's
there's 15 more voicemails and we just
can't I don't think this is the right
venue
uh that is not Whitney that is not
Whitney just for comparison
Whitney called in the middle of all that
and left this voicemail
so I was viewing research throughout
history and like I was trying to figure
out like what a Canyons like what makes
the community and I've decided to like
sum it up and be like really specific
and
um I think it should be like that's the
one
with like a question mark and I think so
all right so anyway as you can see
Whitney called during that and Troy York
also called during that
hey so Mr Pacman there's a oh no sorry
sorry this is the this is a different
guy this is not Troy York Direction
going on with regard to burner phones
and whether or not they're traceable
and people who get their information
either from corporate Media or from cop
TV shows are woefully misinformed as to
how identifiable and how traceable
burner cell phone traffic is well we're
going to look into that we're going to
look into that for sure
um
yeah
Troy York did call in as well
uh I'm wondering what happened to all
your videos you were so convinced that
Matt Gates and the investigation into
him
he was going to somehow force him out
all offense uh what happened to that Mr
I I never said that I'm convinced Matt
Gates is going to be forced out of
office in fact from the beginning I said
I'm not convinced he's even going to be
charged and it's not at all apparent
that there's any interest in charging
that gates from the justice department
it's not clear Republicans would care so
Troy you you must you must be reacting
to what someone else or no one at all
said which is typically what a lot of
these right-wing trolls do they call in
and they say I'm just a terrible person
for saying uh
uh things I never actually said you know
it's it's very very strange
um
uh oh someone has already clipped me
being touched by the Holy Spirit during
the stream look at this
look at this here the whole
oh boy that could end up being memed
that that's a concern I should maybe
should not have done that
the whole
oh man
it's conceivable that I will end up
regretting that
it's conceivable I will end up
regretting that oh boy
all right let's look at some other super
chats as we get close to the rally
have you heard Cedar's new halftime
remix there's a chick on it that sounds
suspiciously like you're Ms Whitney I
have not I have not if if Sam Cedar Is
MeMe jacking Whitney we're in trouble
Andy says David sir
do you have a date for your Patrick Bet
David podcast appearance zhenk weiger
was on yesterday and I'm just kidding
guys I know how to pronounce jenkuger
was on yesterday and it was fantastic
brought the truth heat with Trump
Mansion Cinema no it ended up having to
be rescheduled so I don't have a new
date quite yet
Wendy says Trump supporters on this chat
David
packman speaks the truth and lives in
reality something you not of and are not
used to from Trump keep listening maybe
you learn something beautiful message
Wendy thank you
Denver says it's Whitney that was not
Whitney calling from China no that was a
different caller
that was a different caller I can assure
you
I can assure you
um
guys this has to be a joke
I just got an email from someone saying
please add me to the list for the
donated memberships you cannot get on
the list by emailing me if you want a
donated membership you fill out the form
at davidpackman.com
free membership if you email me it gets
deleted
I cannot put you on the list you have to
fill out the form at davidpackman.com
free membership that is the only way the
only way
do you think these people really believe
that the election can be overturned or
are they just so accustomed to saying it
now that they can't stop I think it's a
mix
I think it's a mix of the two
Adrian says my computer glitched with my
original Super Chat but can you run the
crazy loop with Trump saying Yosemite
uh uh I don't know how I would do that
let me see actually
let me see if I can create a loop
let's see if I can deliberately create a
loop what is what's a funny Trump clip
uh uh let's do the the dating Ivanka one
let me see if I can do this okay let's
have let's all be quiet and see if I can
create a longer one let me see if I can
do this okay let's have let's all be
quiet and see if I can create a bunker
one let me see if I can do this okay
let's have let's all be quiet I started
it too soon I started it too soon I'm
gonna be quiet long enough that we can
get back to zero and then okay everybody
be quiet
if Ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps
I'd be dating her
if Ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps
I'd be dating her
if Ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps
I'd be dating her
if Ivanka were my daughter perhaps I'd
be dating my daughter perhaps I'd be
dating my daughter perhaps I'd be dating
my daughter perhaps I'd be dating
my daughter perhaps I'd be dating
to wear my daughter perhaps I'd be
dating
my daughter perhaps I'd be dating
perhaps
investigation
okay
we're done so it's a stupid thing to do
what we've learned is it it's really
dumb it's not entertaining at all
it's it's completely unentertaining so
we're never going to do that again thank
you I appreciate the idea never
appreciate the 10 bucks appreciate the
idea we're never doing it again uh Nails
by Sherry says how great would it be if
in the middle of a speech the FBI rushes
the stage and arrests him yeah I I mean
yes that would be that would be amazing
it's it's not going to happen but it
would be an amazing thing uh Wow we lost
a hundred viewers during that insane
infinite Loop
um
it was getting pretty scary all right
let's listen see what's going on
followers on rsbn accounts as well again
that's at RSB Network
um if you're watching on rumble or
YouTube make sure to like us give us a
thumbs up yeah
Eric says when someone travels to
another country to work don't you do
your research about said country like
China you do realize it's a communist
country
I don't know I don't know I don't know
about that I don't know what people do
Damien's a stop it's too young yeah the
the infinity loop really was not good it
was not a good idea and I apologize
we're not going to be doing it again
we're not going to be doing it again not
on purpose anyway I guess is what I mean
uh Newsmax is also standing by for
tonight's speech we are expecting uh
mostly lies
with some accidental truths I guess
but it's going to be mostly
mostly just a lie filled screed thanks
to deeper shades of house our friend
Lars Baron Roth uh who has just re-upped
for 23 months on Twitch Prime great to
see you Lars new member number 45.
um I I am determined guys today to get
to 100 new members so let's do it right
now listen to all these things that you
can do the best way to support the work
we do is to get a membership on my
website okay so all you do is you go to
joinpakman.com you sign up if you use a
coupon code like look at this if you do
six the six dollar a month and you use
the coupon code
Obama okay you got to spell it correctly
Obama
the six becomes a dollar ninety-two
insane okay that's an insane deal now
even better if you do it as a monthly
with the code Obama
it's only 1920 for the year which is
like 160 a month okay it's insane and
the code is Obama now if you already
have a membership we can now accept
gifts there's a box here which says is
this a gift if you have a membership you
just check it and you can do this as
many times as you want
and then someone else will get a
membership and if you say well who will
get it I have a list of
553 people who want memberships the next
person on the list is Adolfo Del real
and Adolfo is next in line so when
whenever the next person gifts one on
the website it will go to Adolfo and
then after that I've got
552 other people so we've got a bit of a
supply demand issue uh but it is an
exciting exciting thing
um and of course you can sign up via
twitch Prime that'll help us and if you
make a patreon pledge it'll count double
so we love all of our supporters no
matter where they come from some of them
ask really great questions like Daniel
who says David is your Consciousness
local or is it stored somewhere out of
state country actually I keep my
Consciousness in a hyperbaric chamber so
it's less about the location but more
about the oxygen level
Skittle stew has just gifted 50
subscriptions 50 subscriptions on Twitch
putting us at 95. that is tied for the
biggest single gift we have ever seen 50
is it is we've never had 51. but we've
now had 50 a bunch of times thank you
Skittle stew
also thanks to bean sprout who is new
member number 96 today with the twitch
Prime subscription it's an incredible
thing it really is an incredible thing
and uh I look forward to uh continuing
to deliver some additional gifts here
um let's see
David sir are you aware of the popular
YouTube commentator live streamer Sigma
mail voice Augie RFC he mentioned you in
your show a while ago I am not aware of
such individual
I don't know who that is I will have to
investigate
thanks to John for the Super Chat uh
already addressed that Darren says I
live under Texas Christian conservative
suppression please send help Darren I
don't know how to help you
I wish I did Sir Will trump Bingo be
available for us this evening no I had
so many other things this evening that I
had to set up
that I was not able to set up Trump
Bingo all right let's gift see how Trump
is has this donor live stream we are
trying to we are fighting that that's
exactly what we're funding what we're
fighting the right is so well funded
that we are trying to fight fight
against it so Tyler Thornhill has just
bought a subscription on my website for
someone else okay Adolfo Del real that
is for you you get a free membership
Stephen Hart has just bought a gift
subscription on my website that's number
98 that one goes to met her Ness met her
Ness boom
David Giffin has made a patreon pledge
those count double and that puts us at
100.
let's go for 150.
uh I want to say thanks to Ross Walker
who just signed up on my website and is
number 101 using the code Obama Obama
very much appreciate that if you want a
free membership fill out the form at
davidpackman.com free membership if you
email me it will get deleted
we can't handle it that way we have a
form if you want a free membership you
go to davidpackman.com free membership
also want to say thanks to Laura
kretchmer Laura has signed up on my
website and is new member number 102
and lastly before we continue
cordial wombat and IR geek have grabbed
twitch Prime subscriptions
uh
uh you know they came to me and they
said Mr President sir we're out of
memberships and I said we can just
generate more it's no big deal
um Ryan says here's some left bucks to
fight the Trump machine thank you
thank you Ryan very much appreciate that
we are moments away from Donald Trump
here age hope you guys are as excited as
we are these candidates are incredible I
can't wait to see his energy how it
matches
how it matches like the endorsed
candidates is Whitney the host on rsbn
I'm actually wondering it's a very
interesting
vocal resemblance
Skittle stew has just gifted one more
putting us at 105. appreciate that also
big thank you oh here we get another
gift Brooklyn George has just bought a
gift membership on my website and that
one goes to
I hope I pronounced that correctly
oh these inner this inner this woman on
the right is crazy so we saw an
interview with her earlier we also have
a significance of Michigan's rally here
today how does this differ from the
majority of the other rallies so they're
playing Dolly Parton in the background
Dolly Parton hates Trump and would be
disgusted and I would love to see her uh
tell them to stop playing her songs same
convention is April 23rd and that's
significant for both the Attorney
General as well as the Secretary of
State we've got Matt uh Matt deperno and
Christina caramela who are running and
Michigan is a unique State because as we
were talking about they use a delegate
pool to vote so the voters don't
actually vote in the primary here in
Michigan it's the state party's pick
which delegates vote the woman on the
left isn't even paying attention she's
not even paying attention to what's
being said
that actually get to vote in the primary
those are the delegates and so this
convention really was about getting the
delegates to see the popularity and see
the momentum and see how popular Matt
guys I think this is a crowd of 260 000
people I think there's 260 000 people at
this rally it's an unbelievable thing
it's incredible how many people are
there I want to say thank you to Adam
Moran who is new member number 107 today
signing up with the coupon code Obama
Obama appreciate that very much also
thank you to skittlestu and IR geek who
have just each gifted an additional
subscription on Twitch there may be a
million people at this rally for people
who don't know the reference Trump
recently said that at a rally there were
87 000 people there were five thousand
people and Trump said 87 000 people were
there
oh that's interesting so I'm being told
that articles say the the capacity of
this venue is 5500 so it'll be
interesting to see if Donald Trump
claims some larger number
um let's see
man there's a lot happening here that
I'm trying to keep up with
the website is maybe going to crash
under gift load people are trying to
gift membership so rapidly at such a
feverish Pace that the website is doing
all it can to stay up wow
wow
a couple other super chats David sir
I've been tweeting about a free
membership and have heard crickets back
from you and Whitney very disappointing
yes the only way to get a free
membership is to fill out the form
569 people are now anxiously awaiting
free memberships if you are uh into
supply and demand
understand that we have demand for 569
memberships and right now I have no
Supply
I am unable to meet the demand
David sir tell us how excited you are
that you can get started planting your
zooks and cukes actually I just made my
order
uh hold on seeds I just made it here's
what I'm going to be planting
okay I've got rainbow F what is it by
the way what does F1 mean
on seeds
does anybody know what that means F1
I have no clue what that means
Formula One it's like it's like a race
car okay
F1 the keyboard key
they're male male carrots okay now
anyway so here's what I've got I've got
rainbow carrots that I'm going to be
planting I've got some peppers called oh
wait are these Peppers or tomatoes
they're called el jefe which means the
chief
um I don't remember if that's a tomato
or a pepper I've got Cherry Bomb organic
Tomatoes I've got glow organic Tomatoes
French breakfast uh radishes that are
going to be going in very strongly sugar
and snap peas and Sun gold Tomatoes
these are all going to be with great
strength I will be sewing these
F1 means means it's the first crossbreed
Offspring okay
okay that's interesting
um so that's what I've got so far and
then depending on whether any of it even
germinates because I don't know what the
hell I'm doing
um I'll just end up going and getting
seedlings from Home Depot if the seed if
the seed doesn't work but French
breakfast radishes nobody has them for
breakfast in France that's the funny
thing but they're called French
breakfast radishes I don't I I don't
name the stuff guys I just plant it
um
F1 is the first filial generation
beautiful
thanks to Raven for the twitch Prime
subscription your number 110 I really
appreciate that very very much so
um let's see what other super chats are
coming in
none okay good good good good
can you gift five memberships on the
website you can unfortunately right now
the only way to gift five memberships is
to sign up five times checking this is a
gift we're gonna try to make a page
where there will be like a drop down and
you can just say I want a gift five or I
want to give 10 or whatever we're just
not there yet we're not there yet
but uh yeah are there any better coupon
codes so
um there is a secret coupon code instead
of Obama you can use the coupon code sad
Trump all one word we're not really
making like a bit we're not publicizing
it but it is available it is available
to people it's very very complicated uh
it's a very complicated code but it is
available for sure
we are moments away from Donald Trump
let's see if we can squeeze in like one
maybe one or two more voicemails here
um let's see
hey good thing about Matt Gates Marjorie
Taylor green and bobert all those the
sex and Drug thing is all true
oh Bergdahl
I don't know what that is to do with
anything
they said sir the capacity is only 5500
I said no problem I can generate space
for a hundred thousand people to fit in
yeah
um
oh here's one about Trump rallies let's
listen
99 of the people that go to Trump
rallies aren't tend to you and me
they're in a cult political cult true
whatever dear leader says is the truth
right they will
believe dear leader over their own Lying
Eyes Yep this is a cult and the scary
thing is
most of the time when the cult leader
goes off the deep end
pies or whatever the cult will disappear
pressure off and become nothing I don't
believe that will happen with the mega
call I believe Marjorie Taylor green
will take the mega Colt over and she'll
become the ear maker
I think this is going to be a problem
these people are committed
to tearing down our democracy and
ushering in a process religious
yeah I mean a lot of good points being
made
a lot of good points being made
apparently our website is still handling
the membership load better than truth
social I'm being told that very strongly
that's interesting yeah
uh okay let's gift a couple more
subscriptions I have two new gifts to
give away Beth Graham has purchased a
gift and Cindy page has purchased a gift
that puts us at 112. the next two people
to get gifted subscriptions on my
website are Braulio Rivera
and Tyler Thornhill
congratulations we've been able to give
away two more uh Gordon Hall now getting
a gift Gordon's membership goes to man
this is great Aaron Reardon Aaron
Reardon has gotten a free membership we
are now down to 574 people waiting for
memberships also want to say thank you
to Nigel Moffett
as well as oh and Cindy page also
getting a membership for herself using
the coupon code Obama Obama thank you to
Christopher Martin and Connor Boyd
getting themselves some memberships
we'll we'll keep gifting them as they
come in absolutely absolutely also
thanks to slip and shank slip and shank
with the twitch Prime subscription let's
listen to what's being said here
thousands of people still can't come
inside and see President Trump I know
they're so disappointed about that I do
want to remind you guys great time right
now to go to mypillow.com and use promo
code RS yeah so guys you have two
options if you're in the coupon code
world tonight you have two options you
can get Mike pillow products with a
coupon code or you can get a membership
on my website with a coupon code or even
gift one to someone else it's your
choice it's pillow or joinpakman.com you
guys uh you guys decide
um we are standing by any moment now any
moment now Trump is expected to speak
Gregory asking sir will Mr Trump discuss
his policy positions this evening
looking forward to scholarly political
discourse tonight not exactly the types
of things you're going to hear tonight
are are things like this you know it's
called science elements of medical one
of the wettest we've ever seen from the
standpoint of water if Ivanka weren't my
daughter perhaps I'd be dating her and
God bless
the United States very very large a
brain surrounded by water big water for
sure you are a rude terrible person okay
that's what we're expecting tonight
unfortunately hey David just sending you
my love says Robert between how sparks
and yourself I get the real news and
Truth on every issue thank you for all
you do remember I'm just doing
commentary I want every you know you
know how these right Wingers often say
just listen to me I'll tell you the
truth remember I'm doing commentary if
you want to be informed make sure that
you know who's doing good reporting okay
Associated Press Reuters rooters
Roto-Rooter all of them okay very
important I'm the last person to be like
oh no no you got to just listen to me uh
fact check me keep me honest all of it
okay please
phone lines after the rally oh I don't
know today I've got a big night ahead of
me I don't know that I can do phones
today necessarily
Dean says David I've sent you numerous
letters via messenger pigeon as well as
via Morse code and smoke signals
regarding the free memberships shocking
you've not received one yet truly
shocking you've not received one yet I
want to say thank you to Damien Hill for
the patreon pledge those count double
today meaning we're at 120. also we're
about to gift some more memberships
Brittany blockman
has just gifted a membership that's
number 121 Britney's gift goes to Sherry
blumenstein thank you and
congratulations to Sherry
also thanks to Harmony Cannon Ryan
spendlove Mark and Jenny Dawson and
Matthew I don't know if it's gee or G
but it puts us at 125 and Gordon Hall
gifting one more and this one is going
to Todd Wilson if you'd like to request
a free membership fill out the three
field form at davidpackman.com
free membership
David sir you're a typical leftist
blaming the supply chain for the lack of
memberships look inwards and blame your
illegal coupon codes Hogan
well said
don't know I can do any better than that
it's easy to take a person out of a cult
but hard to take the cult out of the
person Watch the documentary on Heaven's
Gate well said
very well said Darren I I agree with
that
um it looks like we are now moments away
for nights I was talking to someone who
camped out last night
someone camped out for this there are
people where people sitting down it
looks like they're all standing up
they're anxiously awaiting him to
come on out
guns are here look at this
there's like a dozen of them I
absolutely love it
Phil Collins I can assure you is not a
fan of Donald Trump's and almost all the
music being played here is that this is
like a circus guys this is a circus look
at this it's wild but it is exactly what
someone who loves America would be doing
and should be doing I don't think
anyone's ever I know no one's ever done
this before all right what use use nuns
as political props no I think people
have used nuns as political props before
kind of C
that we're gonna get closer as this
those those VIPs start to come out from
see from the party in the back
it is crazy that this is the United
States at this point in time
please do not refer to him as president
refer to him as former or presidential
Loser yeah failed president Donald Trump
is about to give a speech and the term
speech is a little bit you know
it's probably a bit much probably a bit
much
um okay I've got a bunch no I've got one
more membership to give away Veronica is
it is it pronounced Aguirre has gifted a
membership on my website and that one
goes to Anna Laurent Anna Laurent we are
now down if you thought oh I'm not gonna
gift one because there's nobody left
waiting there are now 585 people waiting
for free memberships they're just
waiting
thanks also to Veronica for getting
herself her own membership Joel Staley
has signed up very much appreciate that
uh oh and I've got one more gift to give
away Tyler Thornhill has gifted another
one that's number 130 and that
membership goes to Patrick lever lever
beautiful
um
former social media influencer Donald
Trump yeah exactly
that's not inaccurate
thanks to Sobe for resubbing on Twitch
appreciate that yeah it's a big night
we're very curious as to how many lives
we'll be told tonight does Trump say
anything more about 2024
does he praise Vladimir Putin
a lot of people have been asking for new
pronunciations of Putin like Putin or
Putin
uh uh poutine is offensive to the
delicious
uh quebecois dish poutine so that I'm
not not I don't know that I'm big on
that necessarily
[Applause]
all right we officially have the best
spot in the house we keep our camera
behind us for a little bit of the show
well because we are interviewing we
don't want to be we want to be able to
step in front of the camera anybody
understanding what that lady's talking
about I'm really not
um
Brian Taylor Cohen recently interviewed
Biden when will Jesse Lee Peterson be on
your program again I think he's only
been on once
but he's welcome anytime
do you need to add nuns to the Trump
Bingo board yes nuns being a dozen nuns
being trotted out is not a crazy thing
to have on the Bingo board now
apparently
um how long do we expect the speech to
go Trump's speech lately have Trump's
speeches lately have been shorter he has
not been doing the hour 40 hour 50
minute speeches he's been doing shorter
uh hour five hour ten however it's often
because of the weather he gets cold
today's speech is indoors so it's
certainly plausible that it will be back
to the full length and width
for lack of a better term thank you to
Brad bashind who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code sad Trump
so people have been asking when we're
going to have a maxillco code Mexico the
problem is it's kind of hard to
understand the spelling like it could be
m-e-x-i-m-e-x-e
it sort of sounds like at the end like
sometimes he says Mexico cone rather
than an Excel Co
s so I don't it we I always want simple
codes that's why band men would be a
great code and we will bend men right
that one would work I love it when Trump
says look at all the fake news and it's
only right-wing cameras covering him
right the only the only uh entities in
the room at this point are right side
broadcasting a Newsmax and Trump still
points to the back and says look at all
the fake news
it is weird it's very weird I don't know
that he gets it someone might want to
inform him that that's that's the
situation at this point
but it's uh it's all very sad let's see
if our friend Ron Phillip Phillip Kowski
has any new on the ground images or
video for us no not really
um let's see if we've got anything else
from the event
uh we have the bombshell evidence
there's only one machine in the United
States now where we have you where you
open up and there it all is yep the only
that the only machine where we have that
is my laser printer that's the last
machine left it's the last it's the new
frontier of machines only my laser
printer has that information right now
and that was uh Tina Peters took her
back um took a a copy of you know backed
up her computer last summer right when I
had my Symposium she was there from
there you guys remember the zabozium
right you've not forgotten about that
time on at least eight different cybers
cyber cyber experts cyber experts did a
seven month investigation yep after
seven months they were like are is
anybody gonna get us the machine because
we've been waiting all this time for it
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machine
yeah
hello David and fellow pacmaniacs wanted
to say high in godspeed for the rally
have to go play music don't forget to
play the curb theme after
we've got it we've got it
um I want to say thank you to Angela
wood and Tyler Thornhill gifting two
more memberships on my website the lucky
recipients are Vin Quinn
and Amanda Tucker
we are now down to
587 memberships can you imagine
587 different people right now are
waiting for memberships on my website
and it's as simple as hitting that is
this a gift button and you can just gift
them huge dumps of gifted memberships
are coming in
some consider the memberships medicinal
that's true that's true listen they have
more active ingredients than Homeopathy
let's be frank I mean it's if you say to
me what's more likely to cure insomnia a
membership or homeopathy
it's probably the membership I mean
there's at least an active ingredient
there you know
um thanks to shorty for the twitch Prime
subscription as well I appreciate that
by the way none of my comments about
memberships have been evaluated by the
FDA just to be really clear
Trump is real Rhino and having nothing
in common but white powder and parties
with GOP why doesn't rsbn get banned for
copyright flubs thanks David quirky we
love you I don't know what you're
talking about but I absolutely it's so
great to see you here
um David sir ever noticed the anchors on
these networks are Playmates in tight
skirts hired for their journalism I'm
sure listen I don't I don't really want
to make this about physical appearance
but I don't find this anchor even
remotely attractive
so if she's there for her look someone
has really really failed and I'm sure
she's a great person and has you know
I'm sure her personality is great and
everything but uh
since it's been brought up I'm just not
sure about that
I don't know about that it's refreshing
to see Tim Poole has 40 000 viewers on a
mundane Tuesday and you're struggling to
fold 5K even with the help of trump
absolutely we're circling the drain
actually
this show may be over very very soon
Mike pillow needs to come back on your
show and expose all the computer and
voting corruption in the United States
yeah
he should expose how antivirus programs
function like uh like like malware and
you can't get them off
can you it's it's crazy how is that even
allowed
let's give away some more memberships I
want to say thanks to Angela wood svelt
duck and Ashley flooring who have just
gifted three more and those are going to
D McMahon David Meyer and Kelly Coleman
very much appreciate that
Nicholas says you've got to Google this
venue as a fellow michiganer trust me
it's a dump and the bathrooms are
terrible Michigan Stars Sports Center it
doesn't seem exactly like you know the
best venue yeah you're I I you're
completely right
nasty questions has just resubscribed
via twitch Prime and is asking for an
Obama sure Obama always glad to oblige
um
oh thanks also to Jessica Barnes Jessica
signing up at joinpakman.com number 140
today Trump running a little late not
Not Unusual rhinos in place and they're
just not going to do it the music is
dimming Let's uh see if perhaps this is
his walkout song is dimming an
appropriate term for music or would you
say fading tip I'm familiar with lights
dimming and music fading
but you guys tell me
I'm not sure about that
the lights are fading the music is fake
yeah no that's interesting it's an
interesting one oh do you have a few
minutes before President Trump walks out
go to the website I don't know the last
thing I bought was on mystore.com yeah
don't go to don't don't do that don't do
that
don't go to that website that's that's
the wrong website to go to but I can
assure you let's see if we can squeeze
in one more voicemail here
um do I have anything
about the rally
not really
not really I don't know that I have
anything for you guys on board I mean I
have like a thousand voicemails but
um
yeah I don't know that I really there's
any voicemails I'm particularly drawn to
play for you guys right now
some of them seem very weaponized yeah
for a home user all you need is
Microsoft Defender if you're in a
business or Enterprise setting I hope
you have EDR and backup Solutions
beautiful
sir can we raid our place the destiny
Community was kind enough to start the D
in David Pacman well I don't even know
what that is and he's banned so I'm just
not sure I don't even understand any of
that I don't understand any of that so I
want to be really careful thanks to Cole
Bertola for gifting a membership on my
website the recipient of that membership
is Ron Williams congratulations to Ron
um yeah I just are I don't know what our
place is I don't even know what that is
let's see
it's some kind of subreddit but
yeah I don't know I don't know I just
don't even understand what people are
talking about
the crowd is getting very very hyped up
nothing like Trump coming out to speak
to calm them down and kind of put them
into a uh
almost like a
like a meditative state
it gets very strange yeah the crowd
usually in the middle gets very bored
um
they're selling slippers now that's odd
to say the least
do you think Mike pillow screams into
his pillows at night listen I hope Mike
pillow has never strangled anyone with
those stupid pillows that he sells I
really hope it's not the case that he's
ever done that Yami Yoshi has just
subscribed via twitch Prime welcome Yami
Yoshi great to see you here appreciate
that we are standing by for Donald Trump
due 19 minutes ago
um
and it looks like from the songs that
it's getting closer party and it's
such a move now
and they're gonna love it and of course
uh they got towels and the sheets and
all this the dog beds if you got a dog I
do that as well uh a mic pillow dog bed
there's an idea
uh Norris has finally caught you live
love your videos great to see you Nora
welcome to if this is your first live
stream welcome welcome welcome we've
we've gone over a number of different
things already and it's looking like
it's going to be quite a delusional
evening so on that basis I'm really glad
to have you here to Bear witness to the
insanity I guess or at least so I'm not
the only one experiencing it if I have
to suffer through it I at least want
some other people to as well
um
and they're fortunately there there are
some of you here I appreciate that
um when are we doing the twitch Town
Hall okay I'm gonna be really clear here
okay so listen very carefully because I
don't want to have to keep answering
this it's not a complicated number
when we get
to 100
000 twitch followers we will do a
multi-hour twitch exclusive Town Hall
where the phones are wide open so the no
it's not it's not a difficult number to
remember it's not like 94 762 it's not
ninety nine thousand nine hundred and
eighty six it's just 100K okay so when
we get to 100K on Twitch to celebrate we
will be doing a multi-hour twitch
exclusive Town Hall where we were open
the phone lines I will take good
questions and bad questions alike I will
take questions from people with terrible
audio and people with good audio uh
that's the it's a very easy to remember
number one hundred thousand
Darren says I think my hairline is
dimming right exactly it's not fading
it's dimming
thank you to Joanne Howard who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code Obama and in all seriousness guys
we have a good time joking around about
memberships and voicemails and you know
all these different things in all
seriousness
you guys are our main funding source and
so if you have been enjoying the more
regular streams and all of the different
coverage the podcast the YouTube channel
the radio show all these different
things the tick tocks by the way we're
now exploding on tick tocks uh sign up
on my website in all seriousness grab a
membership at joinpakman.com all of
these other platforms they're T they're
greedily taking slices you send a dollar
and they take 30 cents and you send ten
dollars and they send they take four
it's crazy what they're slicing slicing
slicing we pay 2.9 percent to swipe
credit cards and debit cards on our
website and all the money then just goes
directly to the production of the show
so when we say it's the most direct way
it's not an attack on Twitch or YouTube
or any of these platforms it's just
we're controlling the entire process
from start to finish which is crazy
is it some kind of cult psychology to
always come late to your own rally yeah
Trump's been more on time lately though
to some degree but it's being the best
way possible because she is just so
smart and hardworking and oh my God
I don't even understand what's happening
with the cameras they're just shaking
thanks to re-grandma X tamstu and Titan
Mars production as well as blue light
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
really appreciate that that's exciting
stuff I also am going to be gifting
another membership Raquel Vazquez just
gifted a membership on my website and
that membership goes let's see who's
next to Aries Javier
we have been able to gift 23 website
memberships today there are
593 people still waiting for one
thank you to Kristen Mahoney as well
thanks Kristen really appreciate uh you
signing up on my website you are number
149.
do you think Trump will mention his hole
in one
I think it's uh 50 50. I don't know well
Trump mention his hole in one maybe yeah
I'm not totally sure he may
depends how bored the crowd gets I get I
guess
when the crowd gets bored Trump will
kind of try to bring up stuff to make
them more interested
and by the way we should say it
the alleged hole in one because the
video that they've published doesn't
actually show him making a hole and
wallet it just shows a ball in in you
know in the cup
uh so it's
it's not totally clear to me that it
really happened but it may have it may
have
quite frankly I don't care one way or
the other
whether Trump got a hole in one or not
he was still a failed president
oh we did get a voicemail about that
crazy uh oh oh oh let me mention that I
don't know how many of you saw that I
interviewed a trumpian Republican
presidential candidate the other day oh
sorry trumpian Republican Congressional
candidate named Darlene swoffer and I
started with a simple concussion
protocol question which sometimes if
you've like had a stroke or maybe a
brain injury or a concussion they'll ask
you who's the president just to be like
okay so you're with it right here's how
it went with Darlene who's the current
president
well I don't believe that uh the current
president is a is a legitimate president
and we'll leave it at that is Joe Biden
currently the president even if you
think he's illegitimate is he the
president
I don't believe he is I don't believe
that is the current legitimate president
and who is the current legitimate
president
we have a current legitimate president
wow so in a sense there's no President
of the U.S right now
I guess that's your interpretation of
what I said but okay well you tell me I
mean is there a president right now I
guess
well I I'd rather not answer that how's
that because I kind of feel like you're
leading down an area of controversy yeah
it's very it's like a it's gotcha
journalism and I'm kind of setting her
up to sandbag her in an unravelable
spool of uh logic when I ask the
question who is the president which is a
concussion protocol question
um that we don't have to go okay
interesting
okay so anyway there there's that uh
basic basic brain injury screening uh
not not a question that she's uh willing
to answer so that that was pretty insane
it was it was completely nuts
you should play send in the clowns when
we're waiting probably copyrighted but
just the music no words another free
member beautiful
um we'll look into that let me let me
check into that I don't I don't know
if that's easily accessible to me right
now thanks to Rich bird Nation new
member number 150 today let's go for a
record let's let's go for 200.
um I want to say thank you to Carrie
Turner
looks like scrumps is appearing here hey
Trump
oh God also want to say thanks to aah
new members
151 and 152 Trump already visibly
sweated sweating that right eye swollen
almost completely shut we still don't
know why that happens but it does but it
does
God Bless the USA
oh man
he is hinging forward at the waist he's
not gotten away from that thanks to
extamstu who has just gifted a
subscription on uh on Twitch number 153
also thanks to experiment who just
signed up with the message Obama Obama
we are going to be hearing from Donald
Trump tonight about his uh new renewed
commitment to getting away from fossil
fuels and towards green energy as well
as to bringing a more respectful and
civil tone to American politics Trump
will also weigh in completely soberly on
what would be
um a fair tax rate for billionaires and
who the hell am I kidding he's not going
to do any of that stuff he'll probably
just insult Biden
none of that stuff I just mentioned is
going to happen I I if I for 30 seconds
you got your hopes up that he was going
to do those things I just said
I'm sorry because he's not
thanks to Eva Wilburn new member 155 on
my website today
there are uh if you missed it there was
a group of uh a dozen or so nuns that
were trotted in
about 15 minutes ago unclear if they
will play some kind of a political role
and last reminder the venue fits 5500
people if Donald Trump talks about
there's 30 000 people here there's 50
000 people the venue has a capacity of
5500 bit remember that that's a key
number for today
If he if he tries to claim otherwise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
edgy Super Chat I'm not even gonna read
it because it's very very edgy
thank you thank you
wow that's some crowded we have
thousands of people outside
[Laughter]
Michigan it's great to be with you good
to be with you so nice
and we just came in we have thousands
and thousands of people outside
and I wish this building were about four
or five times larger but we love you and
we put it oh God you guys called it and
I hope they hoped and see it and it's
not that cold
cold I went to South Carolina it was the
coldest night they have on record it was
29 degrees I said that's cold it can't
be true that that's the coldest ever in
South Carolina we can now hear and all
over the country they love us and we
love you thank you very much
yeah Trump looks all wet thrilled to be
back with you in your beautiful state
with thousands and thousands of
hard-working proud American Patriots
that's what you are you built our
country
seven months from now the people of
Michigan are going to fire the radical
left Democrats who are destroying our
country
and you're going to throw out Gretchen
Whitmer the job that she's done who are
we thinking is the most comical person
visible in the background right now
maybe guy in the red hat with the
glasses over Trump's right shoulder
first Republicans up and down the ballot
and together we are going to end crazy
Nancy Pelosi's political career once and
for all
I mean she's gonna retire soon they'll
probably take credit for that but term
elections could not be higher I don't
think we've ever had a time in our
country where we felt so low so dejected
what's going on is absolutely
unacceptable we're living through the
most dangerous period of our lifetime
and we have a president who has no idea
what's going on he has no idea what he's
doing and he's got no idea what he's
saying or where he is
other than that he's doing a fantastic
job
the presidential election was rigged and
stolen and because of that that's a lie
this is a cult guys do not be confused
this is a cult
just stop our country's Decline and make
America great again
foreign
the radical left touches turns into a
catastrophic mess the likes of which we
have never seen before to this extent we
have never seen anything like it before
Biden and the Congressional Democrats
triggered massive inflation no they
didn't
who would possibly believe that being
crushed by the highest gas in food
prices in the history of our country can
you believe it
[Applause]
I want to know what Joe Biden did to
raise the prices of gas in Suriname
Democrat run cities
officers along with police officer
deaths have more than doubled in a
single year and violent carjackings are
ravaging Detroit Chicago Minneapolis and
Milwaukee and many other cities that are
raped never before seen think of it
Biden is appointing far left crazies to
the federal bench and ordering the Dem
and you know what's happening here with
the Department of Justice now that was a
glitch that was a brain glitch did you
guys notice he caught on the word and
twitched that's the we don't know what
that is but that is the brain glitch
that he's had for years now
re-enter the disastrous nuclear deal
that I terminated that was a great
termination we would have had a deal had
the election
been different we by the way
by the way we had some great election
and new people delivered unfortunately
the vote counters Biden won Michigan you
guys know that right
yeah we did win
we did one
what a cult
and these people are dangerous that's
the thing these people are dangerous but
we won by a lot not just a little bit
but won by a lot
Biden delivered the single actually
let's let's go over here
surrender in Afghanistan which it was
terrible
and now Biden's weakness has given us
the Ukraine disaster
is also now pleading with the Venezuelan
dictator to sell us well what do we need
his oil for we have so much right under
our own feet more than any other country
we have liquid gold
under our own feet and we're dealing
with Venezuela a far cry from the Trump
Administration where we were energy
independent for the first time we're
energy independent still I've gone
through the data on my show this is
another lie the people in the room don't
have a clue what's going on like a long
time ago but we were energy independent
we were selling oil to other countries
we were making an absolute fortune and
you remember when not so long ago a year
and a half ago one dollar and 87 cents a
gallon remember that so it was 220 and
it was like a year and a half ago and it
was the middle of a pandemic and I mean
you guys know you guys know said that
and I said you're going to be trading in
your big luxurious cars and trucks
for little tiny cars
the choice this November is very simple
if you want high crime high prices high
taxes High corruption and high
incompetence vote for the radical
Democrats if you want
a country that is strong Sovereign
solvent safe and secure you must vote
for America First Republicans have to do
it
foreign
[Applause]
catastrophes perhaps none is more
dangerous or devastating that is
complete annihilation of America's
borders what's happening what's
happening what when I left office we
handed the new Administration the most
secure Border in the history of our
country we never had a border so secure
ever before and that includes drugs
coming in we never had anything like it
we had ended Catch and Release we had
stopped Asylum fraud and built nearly
500 miles of beautiful wall just like
the border patrol wanted
our border was sealed wait so was it 500
or was the entire border wall almost
done as he's been said many times before
but then Biden and the open borders
these extremists these sick sick
extremists systematically dismantled the
border security measures we put into
place and brought illegal aliens
streaming across the southern Border in
numbers like we've never seen before
and the real numbers are even higher
than those being reported they're at a
level that nobody's even thought
possible
just yesterday the Biden Administration
terminated the critical title 42
protection that I put into place to
ensure John tobacco is that could that
possibly be real and to end title 42
Biden will be opening the floodgates to
a far greater extent than even now
and we will be deluged by illegal
immigration like no country has ever
witnessed or had to endure an estimated
half a million illegal aliens per month
and now it's probably even a million
people per month are pouring into our
country and you have many many of these
people are criminals this could be 12
million people a year that's a big
percentage of the people in our country
it's it's completely untrue million that
is commonly being reported that's fake
news by all those people oh look at all
those people remember the only people in
the back are right-wing media that's
it's a right-wing media and US covering
this trash
as fake news
this could be 10 or 12 million people
coming in a year this is incredible
what's happening and that getting rid of
all of these you know remain in Mexico
you know about remain I made a deal with
Mexico remain in Mexico don't come here
he ended it he wanted to end the deal
and now the courts are forcing him
because they say we had a deal so he's
going with a much
a much more somber deal not a good deal
and not a proper deal and not a deal
that's going to work remember as almost
everyone said I was right about
everything and that's true I was right
about it
the border the military yeah they've
canceled indoor Heating and Cooling just
like he said Biden would this woman
seems to be having a grand old time huh
medical Democrats are spending billions
and billions of dollars trying to secure
the borders
of distant foreign countries many of
which you've never even heard of
but I believe you've never deserve a
president who will secure our borders
the borders of our nation who will
protect our citizens who will defend our
sovereignty and who will stop the
biggest Invasion ever of our country and
probably of any country there's never
been anything like it
we're being invaded and that's the word
we're being invaded by millions and
millions of people
many of them are criminals who should
not be allowed into our country we're
going to be paying a price
and a very big one long into the future
you'll wait and see unfortunately I'll
be right about that one too oh yeah and
that includes the thousands and tens of
thousands of people we took in from
Afghanistan they rushed the planes three
percent of those people were entitled to
come back three percent we have
thousands and thousands of people they
Rush those planes and those planes took
off with 28 people falling off the sides
nobody's ever seen anything like it
these people don't know what they're
doing but our country is being
systematically destroyed it's being
destroyed
nothing like this has ever happened to
another country even a third world
country protects their borders at least
a little bit
and let there be no doubt the Biden
Administration is resetting this
humongous wave of illegal aliens in
communities like yours all across
America congratulations and demanding
that you the American Tax okay so when I
said this woman is having a grand old
time I didn't realize so people are
saying I'm making that she has a medical
condition I see now she may have
something parkinsonian going on I didn't
even notice that when I said she was
having a good time I just meant she was
clapping okay I did I'm not making fun
of anyone I now see it I won't talk
about that woman again
you know too many hands are going up
if any part of our country is going to
be turned into a migrant Camp it should
not be the communities of hard-working
Americans it should be the neighborhoods
of the radical left politicians
who have callously thrown open America's
borders
even as Biden has opened our borders to
the largest number
of illegal aliens in history by far
he is handcuffed to our great ice agents
these are brave people these are people
that go all up all over the country they
go into they call them nests nests of
killers and they go charging in and they
take them out and they throw them the
hell out of our country and bring them
back where they came from these are
great people and they're scorned by the
radical left they're keeping your
community safe
our ice agents and slashed if you take a
look at the deportations they cut the
hell out of it they want to get rid of
ice they want to get rid of border
patrol these are incredible Patriots
these are people that are very brave I
see some very tough people on the front
row not not one of those people want to
be a nice station
none of them want to be nice that's
tough ice has been functionally
abolished to Grant Safe Haven to Savage
gang members like MS-13
and vicious criminals just as Arc plus
three you know who AOC plus three is no
Rashida Talib
and Omar that's another Beauty
they've always dreamed this is what they
want
and just like they've destroyed Israel
from within the halls of Congress
they're totally I mean Israel has taken
a hit like nobody no other country's
taken Israel's fine it used to be
hands-off Israel 15 years ago today
Israel is scorned and mocked by these
people like never before
it is scorned and mocked by those people
but Israel's fine
deal with human traffickers
thugs it's happening too the radical
story for dangers criminal aliens
Republicans believe our country should
be a sanctuary for law-abiding Americans
and people that want to live the
American dream whatever happened to the
American dream
you killed it destroy our country and
they want to destroy the American dream
they don't want you to have the American
dream
one of the first bills a republican
Congress will pass yeah the Super Chat
is pointing out that there is a kid on
the stage there's there is a question as
to whether it would be under some some
sense child abuse to bring kids to this
thousands of new agents to find and
remove every single illegal alien who's
causing us unbelievable problems that
unlawfully allowed and was allowed to
come into our country you could take the
first and take it 5 2 12 but you could
take what the five worst Presidents in
American history and probably a hell of
a lot more than that and put them
together and they would not have done
the damage that Joe Biden has done in
our country in just 15 months
the damages
unbelievable anybody seen the stock
market and the unemployment rate
recently I mean like you know some
things are not so good and some things
are pretty good it's hard to argue that
this is the worst America's ever been
I'll fix it
we're gonna fix it what a shame
what a shame
never been a period of time like this is
everyone is saying Russia's outrageous
invasion of Ukraine who would ever
thought this was going to happen I
thought he was negotiating he had a
hundred and fifty thousand soldiers on
the border I said oh he's going to make
a great deal he could have made a great
deal I believe when he saw what happened
in Afghanistan the way we ran
and you know when I was running that 18
months we didn't have one soldier killed
in 18 months
and you've heard me tell the story I
spoke to
I spoke to Abdul and I said oh no
there's no more killing of our soldiers
Abdul
well you're going to be hit so hard
you're going to be hit harder than
anybody has ever been here
but why but why your Excellency do you
send me a picture of my house
not this story again
you'll have to ask other people that
question
but you know what he never now one
person was killed for 18 months and
Biden even said that he stood up he said
well I have to say
nobody was killed in 18 months at which
case the television cameras were
turn off those cameras they didn't like
it when he said that none of that
happened I didn't like it but it's
through 18 months and then we lost 13
but you know they don't talk about how
horribly so many of them were wounded
with the legs and the arms and the face
and everything else
but this invasion of Ukraine would never
have happened
if I was in the White House not even a
chance would have never happened would
have never happened
not even
and I knew Putin very well you know they
say oh he knows Putin he knows Putin no
that's a good thing not a bad thing I
know Kim Jong-un I know president XI of
China
and you know what we had no conflict
remember North Korea is going to be a
nuclear war according to Obama and
everybody else we're going what happened
didn't happen although I tell you he's
getting he's not happy he doesn't like
the person in office right now but
nothing happened we kept you safe we
rebuilt our military at a level that
nobody thought possible
just I love that because this one's
indoors and like a gym it's so echoey
that like the lone crazy people yelling
stuff the entire speech are way more
more uh annoying than when it's just
outdoors and their voices go into
nowhere instead of doing the trick then
they say Trump's friendly to Russia
really I'm the one that revealed
the pipeline note strip too you never
heard of the pipeline nobody there's
these crooked people back here they're
crooked is a
four dollar bill
can't say two dollar bill because they
actually make two dollar bills
yeah that's a crooked a lot of people
don't know there's two dollar bills the
press in this country is corrupt
they're corrupt and they know it too
[Applause]
all you had to do is look at what the
New York Times just announced recently
that's all you have to do in fact I
stand
as the only president of the 21st
century on who's watched Russia and
Putin did not invade another country in
fact I told the story
I mean with separatists they were
occupying the Donetsk and luhansk but um
[Applause]
Let's Meet the Press
press
or to Face the Nation right one of them
but they asked whether or not uh they
were talking to blinken is another
Beauty
and they said how come nothing happened
like with Ukraine with Taiwan with North
Korea how come nothing happened with
Iran they were ready to make a deal they
would have made a great deal now they
want billions and billions of dollars
but the good news is
they were very smart you know what they
did they got Russia to negotiate our
deal with Iran that's a good one and you
know who's helping Russia negotiate the
deal China
that's going to be a good and you know
how many points we won no points
so we have Russian negotiating the deal
with China as a backup
how stupid is this country very very
very very very very deal is a disaster
it's turning out to be nobody can even
believe it but we're giving everything
away all the things that we fought for
with Iran they would have made a deal
within one week after we took office
they would have made a deal they were so
ready to make a deal
we had sanctions well that's a good
question we can do a lot
we can do a lot
we can do a lot and you know what we
have cards we had all the cards we still
have cards if they knew how to play them
they still have cards
the only thing they're good at is fixing
elections that's about the only thing
they do fixing elections
rigging him also during my four years
China never invaded Taiwan did they yeah
now they're sending planes over they're
sending bombers over
you had a president who not only
completely rebuilt our military
including
the addition of space force remember
they smiled
remember that look at this guy
this guy loves space force right here
this guy in the Hat he loves it
go space force it's going to be very
important having it you know if you look
at China and Russia
they had a big lead and right now we're
leading because we did that that was so
important but they left did the camera
just move there's completely different
people visible now on stage behind them
the woman with this really beautiful red
hair
she left
and she was hit so hard by the military
because they knew I was right the
military understood I was right you know
she's going to msdnc you know that right
[Applause]
right
they need a redhead they don't have a
redhead over there so they need a
redhead
but you also had a president who always
put our country first it was America
first always
I read an entire 500 page book about Jim
Jones and the people's Temple
there's a hell of a lot of overlap
between that cult and this one
thank you
what an incredible Spirit you know the
rallies we have now are bigger than the
rallies from before the election because
people are so angry wrong they're so
angry not true
the radical left Democrats put America
last and that's where they intend to
keep you they want to put us last
and nobody understands why what the hell
are they doing nobody really understands
this like
do they love our country maybe they
don't love our country the only way you
can do the things they're not stupid the
only way you can do what they're doing
is you have to hate our country
historians will record this period of
American history as a catastrophic low
point and a stain Upon Our once true but
that they're going to say that about
Trump's four years get rid of that stain
[Applause]
never has our country been treated with
such disrespect and scorned by other
world leaders they treat us like they
don't even know this guy he calls them
up we haven't had a chance to call him
back two weeks later
no they don't even return his phone
calls I believe it started after the way
in which we withdrew from Afghanistan
and when they looked at our borders the
way they were taking advantage of us on
the borders was so bad you know with
they see it millions and millions of
people coming in when they saw that
other countries smart they did things
that nobody could believe that they were
willing to do and they saw the dead
soldiers they saw the wounded soldiers
they saw leaving American citizens right
now they're called hostages you have
many citizens
that the Taliban is holding they didn't
get enough with the 85 billion dollars
maybe we ought to go in and take it back
dumbest thing I've ever seen
finest military equipment in the world
they have them from the goggles to the
700
000 machine guns rifles guns you know
they're one of the largest arms sellers
in the world now they're selling much of
the equipment because they can't use it
70
000 trucks
now I don't know anything about the
automobile business except that I saved
it for your state okay but how many take
the biggest car sales person and Company
in the country they don't have 70 000
cars or trucks 70 000 trucks many of
them armor plated many of them worth
millions and millions of dollars
and they have it now and then they did
us the great honor of having a parade
two weeks after we left using the word
left
very nicely because I don't like the
word surrendered but we surrendered and
there was no reason to they had such
they were they were fine they were
behaving I said nobody being shot
we were going to get out we were there
21 years I'm the one that got it down to
2 000 soldiers but I was going to keep
Bagram you had to keep aggram a big Air
Force Base that's one hour away from
where China makes its nuclear weapons
think about that one hour away
we've never seen anything like this
before but we will come back and we will
come back strong if you watch
there could be no more Vivid example
than their anti-American energy agenda
inspired by the Socialist joke
known as the Green New Deal we're all
environmentalists we want clean air we
want clean water
you know it's pretty amazing right so
China is very dirty
very dirty the air comes up the fumes
come up that everything comes up it
doesn't stay there it floats to the
United States India
I love a lot of people in India but it's
very dirty they have no Pollution
Control the air goes up and the air
floats over to the United States
every one of these countries Russia
take a look at the Arctic they call it
black ice that's from Dirty factories
and yet with lean Arya goes up and it's
lean so who the hell gets it nobody
knows because it's clean
but what are we doing and we're we're
increasing the course you look at these
windmills that are all over the place
ruining Farms warning land ruining our
landscape
and you remember I said it is very
intermittent energy intermittent
remember what I used to say during the
campaign darling darling I'd love to
watch the president I love the president
I'd love to watch him tonight in the
debate
debating mostly the commentators not Joe
what the hell is he talking about
like Chris Wallace
I said Joe why did you and your family
get three and a half million dollars
from the wife of the mayor of Moscow and
Chris Wallace said you have no right to
ask that question how good was that
question now right
the noise causes cancer
this week Biden released a budget that
proposes 11 new taxes on oil and gas
production great time of record high gas
prices which are making our enemies Rich
these uh these these numbers at 150 a
barrel it's going much higher much
higher California now is over eight
dollars a gallon for gasoline
in addition your crazy Democrat Governor
and your attorney general who's vicious
and doesn't have a clue but she is
indeed vicious what she's trying to do
to people
they're trying to shut down Michigan's
life you know this right line five you
know what li who knows what the hell
line five is that a glitch did he just
glitch again
this is a very well-read crowd
but they're trying to shut down line
five pipeline that provides 55 of all
propane gas
in the state of Michigan they want to
close it what the hell are they going to
do when it's closed it's crazy
if Joe Biden was serious about fighting
inflation and helping the middle class
the first thing he would do is walk into
the White House briefing room and
announce that he is immediately and
completely returning the
pro-american energy policies of a
president named Donald John Trump it's
very simple it'd be a very confusing
statement if he made that statement it
wouldn't make any sense
something
so simple it's so simple
gas prices would immediately plummet we
had them down in fact I was having a
problem I got him you guys all know that
basically what Biden can do is tap the
Strategic petroleum Reserve it'll lower
prices five to Fifteen cents a gallon
that's it and it would have no impact on
the gas prices all over the world which
are high everywhere you guys know that
right I don't have to tell you you guys
actually are a well-read crowd I believe
but the consumer I started worrying
about these energy companies gonna make
it
but you know what they produced and they
produce big and we got it up a little
bit and the price of gasoline was at a
record low and your heating and all of
the other things you're electric you
know what's really frustrating and
listen guys if you want no commentary go
watch it on Newsmax or something what's
frustrating about the gas price thing is
the gas price conversation is so simple
like listen gas prices are up all over
the world the president can do three
things when it comes to gas prices
invade a country that produces oil it'll
Skyrocket gas prices
try to eliminate the gas tax that'll
lower gas prices tap the Strategic
petroleum Reserve it'll drop the gas
price 5 to 15 cents temporarily that's
what a president can do on gas prices we
don't need to keep talking about gas
prices Ukraine Ukraine the Mueller
report all of the crap they pulled
despite all of that impeachment hoax
number one oh God look at this Soros
show they've got Soros politics of crime
oh my God what it this is insane but you
know what we produced for the American
people and we produce for our country
better than just about any other
president in history so in that way it
was fun
thank you thank you
you know it's funny somebody said today
is it true that you gave up your salary
I didn't take salary and I figured a lot
of Rich presidents didn't take it
you know what
I was the only one
he made 1.6 billion during his four
years in the White House it would mean a
little more for him to forego his salary
if he said I'm also not going to be
making money from all of my businesses
while I'm also the president four
hundred and fifty thousand four hundred
and fifty thousand so I wouldn't take it
but if somebody stays in one of my rooms
or hotel rooms for five hundred dollars
seven hundred dollars a night it's like
oh I'm dealing with the Arabs I'm taking
advantage now think of it
is he having a stroke right now he would
call the sleeves back there the Press
they would call
they'd say they'd say this did he give
up his salary this month and the answer
was yes
next month did he give up his salary
this month the answer was yes this went
on for four years right
and you know what was written nothing
but you know what if they ever said no
he didn't it would be a front page
headline really these are really
disgraceful things you know we need our
press back we need a fair press we need
a fair press and it would be
it would be
so much easier
to make America great again it really
would it'd be so much easier to make our
country here we have a corrupt press
corrupt like never before nobody could
believe it I dealt with the Press I used
to get great press before I ran for
politics I had great press that's one of
the reasons I guess I read I got such
good press I ran but I had great press
and then all of a sudden I run
and we are of a conservative band it's
that conservative you know what it is
it's really a common sense spent I don't
say conservative I say it's common sense
it is true that nothing about Trump's
policies are conservative they're just
reactionary and ignorant taxes biggest
tax cut in history we want low taxes we
want few regulations biggest regulation
cut in history we want a powerful
military we built the greatest military
two and a half trillion dollars all of
these things I mean it's cut we want
Great Schools we want great schools and
we want Fair school boards not crazy
people
but from the border crisis to the energy
crisis from the Afghanistan disaster to
the Ukraine disaster all of this
is a consequence of the rigged election
right a consequence if we didn't have
that election you would have no
inflation we had no inflation we had
better than no inflation we had one
percent you know they want one percent
they don't want to have they want like
one percent they even like two percent I
like one percent better and if you're in
the real estate business you like
inflation until everything crashes what
happens is you make it a fortune then
everything crashes then it goes Hume it
goes up
and then it comes down but eventually
that happens but we had the best because
we had one percent it was perfect our
gas prices were under two anybody know
what he's talking about some cases
everything was good we had more jobs
ever 160 million jobs we had more jobs
than we've ever had in our country in
history
and that includes today we're seven
million under I really hope he tells the
relatable supply chain story of how it
takes eight months to get a custom
diamond ring from Tiffany right now well
they had had to do when they came in
despite the way they came in is just go
to the beach and relax
we had the borders of we had the low
taxes we had the low regulations
countries were coming into our country
again
they were stopping bringing companies
out of Michigan to move to other states
another not other states because frankly
I will say I said you want to move to
another state if you can move but you
can't move to another country you can't
move to another country
and the truth is I ran twice
we won twice
much for the second time that we did the
first this is literal fascist propaganda
now we may have to do it again
may have to do it again
and just to cover it quickly because I
don't want to take a lot of time but
it's uh please don't coming out this
truth to vote where they found all the
thousands and thousands of ballot
Harvesters you've seen that truth to
vote well you see that that's coming out
in two weeks when do you see those
numbers I think it's four or five
million people cheating those numbers
are coming out now the Press hates like
hell to cover it oh and they go crazy
because they have a lot of live
television I'm talking it's news Max and
right side in the back of the room there
that's it it's right wing media there
the cameras two cares
but right here just quickly in Michigan
your corrupt state official sent out 7.7
million unsolicited mail-in ballot
applications to everyone on the rolls
including people that were dead and
those who no longer live in the state
now remember guys if you send an
absentee ballot to someone who requested
it when alive and they've since died and
they don't fill it out and return it
there's no crime there's no story
there's no big deal it's a it's like
it's literally a non-event you have a
corrupt election
you mail it in and somebody is supposed
to be at a house and they send it back
you're guaranteed to have a corrupt
election your radical Secretary of State
Jocelyn Benson ordered
[Applause]
she ordered election clerks to assume
that all signatures on Maryland ballots
were valid which was later found by the
Michigan State Court
to be flagrantly illegal it was found
what happened they didn't do anything
they didn't make any changes Zuckerberg
he used to kiss my ass at the White
House oh God
sir
Mr Zuckerberg is on the phone he'd love
to have dinner with you sir sure he
flooded local Michigan election officers
with really nearly 17 million dollars
you know
in a great state Nebraska a congressman
is being put in jail over a few dollars
that he possibly didn't even know
anything about he's going to jail a few
thousand dollars and yet this guy gives
417 million dollars to all this it is
strange how no matter what state he goes
to the exact same types of people with
the exact same delusional beliefs show
up in droves who say you're actually the
president and the vaccines turn you into
a squirrel and it's this no matter where
he does it it they they show up a number
of thousands like twenty thousand
dollars and he said he didn't know about
it now who knows maybe he did maybe
twenty thousand this guy did 417 million
dollars among the different states you
got millions you got millions and
millions of dollars here and the
majority went to deep blue areas and in
particular the corrupt democrat-run
cities including the TCF Center in
Detroit that's an honest place
where there was fraud
fraud and major irregularities a lot of
fraud a lot of irregularities but your
Democrats didn't want to look and you
have a lot of rhino Republicans that
would didn't want to look to I think in
many ways the rhinos are worse than the
Democrats because at least you know
where the Democrats are coming from the
rhinos are bad news you know what Rhino
is Republican in name only
so let's get this straight the Democrats
commit massive and overwhelming voter
fraud in the 2020 presidential election
which they still have not been able to
show any evidence of or investigating
and protesting a very crooked election
well that sounds reasonable
the people that corrupted our election
they have no problem the people that are
looking for the truth and they're
looking for the corruption which has
largely been found
they should go to jail
they should go to jail is the evidence
coming soon
Republicans must get tough and smart and
not let them get away with the crime of
the century any longer
as one critical step we have to fire the
radical Democrat officials who gave us
this total Calamity starting with your
socialist Secretary of State Benson and
your Lawless attorney general Dana
nessel she's very terrible she's
terrible
we're joined tonight by two incredible
candidates who are going to beat those
extreme leftists this November uh-oh
they're great people
these are great people I know them well
first I'm pleased to introduce your next
Michigan
Secretary of State this is a wonderful
woman with a beautiful mom and dad who I
just met backstage
Christina caramel
Christina
a high risk reading there hey Mom
come up Christina
Professor a Christian and a true
American Patriot
she is a Fearless Champion for election
Integrity in November 2020 Christina
spent days at the TCF Center in Detroit
and was appalled by the cheating and the
corruption that you witnessed Christina
bravely stepped forward and testified to
the Michigan legislature and I will tell
you she made such an impression that's
why everybody wants to vote for her
right now they love her but the left is
rhinos
didn't care what she said they didn't
want any part they'd say Trump is
winning big he'll do it again no no what
happened in the past
do it again we won't have a one of the
things Trump won't tell you is that
caramo was a main spreader of complete
and total lies about the 2020 election
for months after the 2020 elections any
lie even the ones that would make some
Republicans blush she was willing to
tell
confirmation
confirmation things like that signature
verification the elimination of
Zuckerberg I call them the that's the
glitch boxes
I call them unlock boxes Ironclad chain
of custody protections
and very importantly she wants something
very simple it's called voter ID does
that make sense
so Christina is running to defeat
Johnson
Jocelyn Benson who is absolutely bad
news for this state she's so bad for
this state the Die Hard left-wing
radical who has gutted your State's
election and Technology measures just
weeks after the corrupt 2020 election if
this were only comedy and not a movement
with people that vote
it would just be hilarious right I mean
if it's like if this wasn't actually a
movement where some of these people are
winning prevent a full audit Christina
knows this I just want to ask Christina
I know she spoke before
but I was trying to get here you know we
had very bad weather and they said sir I
don't think you're going to be able to
make it I said my ass I won't be able to
make sure sure
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I said what are our chances of Landing
safely they said at least 90 percent I
said okay let's
now we had very bad weather and there
was no way I was going to miss it and so
I appreciate all the guys that was a
rough trip I never knew an airplane
could be so rough Christina but I just
like to ask this is a everybody really
relates to turbulence on private jets
that's that's if everybody the kid in
the background especially
what you did for our country you pulled
the scale off of so many people eyes of
how there's a cabal of people and
leaderships bent on destroying oh my God
thank you oh my God
we actually pulled the scales off of
their eyes our country and who didn't do
it to advance himself but to actually
fight back thank
you that's your stink oh God it's a cue
nut it's a cue nut didn't vote in the
2020 election and what's so interesting
of all the lies told about me
all that time at the TCF Center knocked
doors for president Trump and turn
around and not vote but then I foiled my
application to vote proving that I voted
in the 2020 election even though
according to the state of Michigan I
didn't vote and there are so many people
across the state where according to the
Secretary of State they voted different
than they actually did vote but where
Insurrection is we're Traders is this q
and on questions but then our media
protects corrupt politicians and
demonizing citizens for speaking up
so I am so excited to be your next
secretary of state to make sure that no
matter who you vote for what you believe
your vote counts and your vote isn't
nullified by an illegal ballot
it scales off revised anti-semitic can
somebody get me some data on that
perspires so many people to run for
office to stand up and fight back
because he cannot do it by himself it's
an army of people across our state who
are fighting back little Mega Warriors
and we're getting the job done thank you
oh my God
that is scary [ __ ] guys
I wanted to speak more come up and speak
again now look Christina feel good about
your vote because somebody voted for you
okay that's what happened many many
people all over the country they go to
vote Republicans like to vote on
Election Day another thing we should go
back to election day not where ballots
are Trump voted weeks early by mail you
guys remember that right
safely supported by you know who is
supporting him right where they throw
our vote Watchers out of you saw that in
Philadelphia in Detroit but the good
news for Christina is that
her vote counted unfortunately it
counted for the person that you would
have never wanted to see in office
because somebody else voted for it that
happened all over people would come in
to Philadelphia Detroit a lot of
different places they're so proud
they're so proud what's funny is the
story The Woman told was that some
people said she didn't vote and she
provided evidence that she did Trump's
talking about people who say they didn't
vote but they go to vote and then
they're told you've already voted it's
the opposite story ma'am you voted this
happened thousands and thousands of time
now some people were angry beyond belief
some people started to cry some people
just left they said this is the system
it's a corrupt system we're like a third
world country and we're going to stop it
and Christina and Matt are going to lead
that effort so thank you if that lady
wins the state is screwed great job and
your parents are beautiful where are
your parents where are they boy oh boy
what look at her mother and her father
they are beautiful thank you thank you
very much you've done a very good job
and you're proud you're proud of
Christina thank you Doug thank you
everyone to support it's so important
these two positions so important and
this is not just the election for this
is crime in your state crime in your
cities this is a lot of different things
but you have to support Michigan's next
Attorney General a great and powerful
lawyer a tough cookie which is what you
need somebody said well he's very tough
that's what you need
who is putting his life and reputation
on the line Matt deperno
oh
this guy's kooky
Matt is a lifelong michigander who has
practice law for 25 years and a
conservative Warrior who will never fail
the people of this state in fact you
know when I first met Matt he was hated
look at this guy
when I first met when I first met Matt
he was a lawyer up here who was hated by
a lot of these weak politicians the weak
ones the Rhinos others loved him because
he got the job done
but he did numbers on them that were
unbelievable in the courts and he really
held them accountable he's a highly
competitive person after the 2020
election Matt led the explosive
investigation to what happened in Antrim
County where among other irregularities
votes were switched by mistake and had
to be isn't that the county where a
Hanukkah brisket voted
oh they said oh oh oh it was just a
mistake oh okay good it was a mistake
the machines made a little mistake thank
you very much for acknowledging after
they get caught gee that was a mistake
After People pointed out that it was
impossible that Trump had lost these are
areas where we had vast majorities and
we lost so when they went in they found
out that the vote was correct except
then they found out that it was a big
mistake and they apologized a hell of a
lot of good that did us
as your attorney general Matt will
defend your second amendment he will
crack down on violent crime and he will
ensure free fair and honest elections
but before he can defeat softer on crime
and she's soft on crime she's only
strong on Republicans Dana Nestle this
fall Matt who is a true warrior and I
mean this he's a tough cookie we need a
tough cookie he must first defeat a guy
who really had a chance to do the job
he's a rhino named Tom Leonard I don't
know him I just hear
pair of horrible things he had a chance
it's hard to tell who looks more
confused Trump or the guy he's talking
about at his chance to correct it he had
a great opportunity to correct it but he
didn't have the guts to do so that's not
what we want he's a rhino he's not going
to do a damn thing Matt
say a few words we love this guy thank
you not too many words though Trump gets
bored
you know
thank you president Trump you are an
inspiration
and a great
week and I say this the greatest
president in the history of this country
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is what the Maga movement is about
remember in January 2017 When Donald
Trump was inaugurated he stood on those
steps in Washington DC and remember that
picture with those two people sitting as
over his left shoulder George W bush and
Barack Obama
[Applause]
I remember that picture vividly because
I don't know if that was supposed to be
a blue line every one of us he said
today
I give the country back to the people
and that
that is what we mean when we say America
First candidates and Michigan First
candidates that's what we're talking
about that's what we're going to do in
November we are going to beat these
Democrats
no longer will we allow the Elites in
this country to control our elections
and to control us
in the spring of 2020
Governor Whitmer shut down our state
this guy reminds me of Dennis Prager in
some way
that's good never
never admit to tyranny
Trump's getting annoyed that this guy's
still talking
as Attorney General
we will change this in this state we
will restore this state back to what it
once was
a constitutional republic
the office back to the law firm for the
people where I will represent every one
of you
but it starts at the convention coming
up
every one of you delegates need to get
to your county let's hope it ends there
for this Donald Trump is still the
leader of this party
assistant
and Donald Trump has come here today and
said to every one of you delegates
support Matthew perno support Christine
caramel so let me hear it from you right
now are you going to do that
[Music]
this right here is the continuation of
the Maga movement and we have Trump just
signaled the sniper because this guy's
been talking too long
thank for that the 45th president of the
United States and I dare say I hope the
47th
thank you thank you
anyway Donald Trump
[Applause]
and he is really tough and it's just
what you need he is a he's a killer we
need a killer and he's a killer in
honesty he's an honest and honest killer
guy who was feared up here I just said I
have to beat this guy who the hell is he
I'm the one that said why don't you run
I'm telling you Matt you're gonna win
and you and Christina have just taken it
by storm everyone loves you both and
you're going to get to the bottom of
everything and you're going to stop
crying just basic crime in the state if
you look at what's happening and you
look at what's happening in Detroit and
other parts of your state it's a
disgrace he'll be there and Christina
will be there these critical nominations
for Secretary of State and attorney
general will take place at the State
Convention on April 23rd but the
delegates for the State Convention will
be chosen at your county conventions on
April 11th so you have the convention
you guys think Trump understands the
system in Michigan we have some of those
great delegates candidates and others
here tonight I'm going to introduce a
few people that have been just
outstanding I love them they know what
went on
they are just they cannot believe what
went on they did so well we did so well
we did much better than we did the first
time we did much much better you know
the most angry person anywhere in this
country is Hillary Clinton because why
the hell didn't you do that for me
she's angry at the Democrats she wants
to know why they didn't do it for her
they're for Law and Order guys
is it Law and Order to lock someone up
who hasn't even been charged with a
crime I don't know it sounds like it's
not due process why the hell couldn't
you have found 10 000 votes for me she
said
she's a very angry person
at the County Convention
I need 11 000 votes give me a break oh
whoa do this for State Convention if
they will support the Trump ticket we
have an incredible ticket of people and
if they won't give you that Assurance
don't give them your vote
[Music]
and remember this is not just about 2022
this is about making sure Michigan is
not rigged and stolen again in
2024. remember that
so whatever you do make sure you send a
slate of delegates to support Christina
caramel and Matt deperno
they're outstanding people they are
unbelievable people I don't do this I
have to be honest I don't do this often
I don't do this often for State people
this is so important what happened in
Michigan is a disgrace it's a disgrace
[Applause]
protect us from a corrupt election
so we're also joined by members of
Congress great people real Fighters for
Trump John molinar John where's John
John thank you very much great job
Warrior thank you thank you say hello to
everybody we have a lot of good friends
and somebody that got a big round of
applause I hear Lisa McLean Lisa
thank you
thank you
great job great job Lisa thank you
Warriors and a great new candidate for
congress who was a brilliant student at
Stanford and Harvard he went to Stanford
he went to it's funny how they brag when
they have those credentials but also
attack those places as worthless
educations of liberal indoctrination
they want it both ways
is running against one of the ten
impeachers
a guy who spells his name
[Music]
m-e-i-j-e-r but they pronounce it Meyer
the hell kind of his spelling is that
it's Meijer but it's actually pronounced
Meyer who the hell do you pronounce this
guy's name no no what an idiot nothing
in Washington
I said how do you pronounce his name is
it measure measure they said it's Meyer
how the hell do you get Meyer out of it
but I'd like to ask John Gibbs to come
up this Meyer thought he was going to
get some free publicity hopefully that
fake vote will cost him the election
John Gibbs a brave man a great man a
brilliant student come on up
first of all thank you president Trump
thank you for the model you provide for
every decent American to stop being
afraid for a change
[Music]
aren't you guys tired of people being
scared of being called names being
scared of being canceled being scared of
their own shadow but president Trump has
shown us a model for all the regular
decent people all around these people
have five followers on Twitter no one's
canceling them being afraid and do
what's right
do you think all these Mama bears these
wonderful and amazing Mama Bears or the
school board meetings we wouldn't be
doing that without president Trump's
leadership and model he provided for how
to stand up against the corrupt system
so let's keep doing that and let's not
be too nice like we always have been
let's start being a little bit tougher
let's start being a little bit more
ferocious let's have some sharp teeth
when we go
it's not we learn from president Trump
that is what we've learned
yeah I'm running against one of the
biggest rhinos in Congress who voted to
impeach president Trump the greatest
president has his first vote
as a congressman he's got to go he's got
to get out of there
thank you
so let's get out in November let's
support the Trump candidates and support
me especially running in the Grand
Rapids area West Michigan Third District
let's go let's get Peter and Meyer out
of there let's support president Trump's
agenda in Congress vote John Gibbs thank
you and thank you president Trump
thank you John right
just a second and just so he was
he was considered by Ben Carson a
fantastic guy to be benren HUD and John
was a missionary for a long while a very
religious person and then he went to
work with other people and did
unbelievably well in Ben Carson asked
him to come I'm not huge on
proselytizing so for me when I hear
someone's been a missionary it's not
doesn't really get me all excited the
smartest people he's ever dealt with and
that's a good recommendation because Ben
is just an outstanding person
so uh thank you John
John is special thank you John also with
us are
state representatives
Matt Maddox have any has anyone ever
heard of Matt
and a really good guy they changed
districts on him uh-oh because I would
have supported him for one thing but
we're going to support him for State Rep
and he's done a fantastic job Steve Cara
Steve where is Steve
Steve Cara thank you Steve
thank you Steve great job we're Banning
the toxic Chatters as quickly as we can
guys what the hell was happening
now we have a candidate for governor who
is very popular who's a fantastic
brilliant candidate Tudor Dixon tutor
thank you tutor
thank you I heard you're doing well too
and we have some State House candidates
and I'd like to introduce these people
because it's very important it all
starts here
Mick Bricker Jackie Eubanks Mike Hodley
Jack Mayer Hoffer
Angela rygas
Jonathan Roca
Rachelle Smith
thank you all some high-risk reading
very they're all endorsed by me every
one of them you're all leading very
substantially I hear and you're going to
give those few names to our friends
right they had a couple of other
recommendations and I'll listen to them
and State Senate candidates Mike Detmer
Jonathan Lindsay they all have my
complete and total endorsements this is
the first time he's ever heard those
names right big big you're leading big
they're all eating big
we were in Texas a few weeks ago 33-0 we
have a good record on endorsements the
Press hates to talk about it his record
on endorsements is about 60 percent
which is slightly better than chance but
remember that he endorses a lot of
incumbents so it's it's not so good
[Applause]
thank you
I hope he goes into his closing
say it and I just see and she's great
thank you very much and there was a guy
that said it and I love him it's not my
thing but I love him too I love him too
thank you very much thank you
is there anything better than a trump
rally seriously
hard to imagine what would we be doing
right now would be sitting home maybe
having a cyst lanced decision eating
eating eating eating calling people
bored and here we are having a good time
trying to save our country right
really
it's true we're saving our country we're
going to save it start right here in
Michigan Trump's like if I wasn't here I
would just be eating uncontrollably so
I'm sure that's what all of you would be
doing too
or
eating he's in Florida it's actually
kind of comedic genius that it took me a
while to get it but that's actually
brilliant we I would just be eating
eating eating
then he says this is a beautiful Sunday
afternoon to be with no no no this is
Saturday
if I ever made a mistake like that
say he should get out of office
immediately
but Biden used to make it all the time
he still does actually they're corrupt
how about he makes a press conference
and they always have like four
Corrections no he didn't mean that he
didn't mean what he said
he didn't mean any of it
actually it's very insulting though you
know you're the president or all these
people that I mean it happened to Trump
all the time Trump was like oh you got
to punish the woman who gets the
abortion and the next day he's like no
he didn't mean that what he meant was
just abortion's bad you but you don't
punish the woman let the mistake stand
for years corrupt politicians shut down
your factories shipped away your jobs
and sold off your industries to the
other side of the world wonderful place
the other side we lost 32 of your
automobile manufacturing business before
I came into office think of it 30
32 34 and I predicted it would only get
worse
and then I was named a long time ago I
was named did you know this a long time
I don't know your chamber of commerce
somebody who the hell knows what it is
they named me the man of the year in
Michigan
[Laughter]
oh that's great and I said they're
stealing your car business and I was
really rebuked they said that wasn't a
very nice thing just ask it but it's the
truth that I was right that was a long
time ago Man of the Year in Michigan
we've been doing this stuff a long time
actually
but with the help of everyone here today
over four incredible years we saved
American Manufacturing
and we did it for the state of Michigan
probably as much or more than any other
state because you guys remember when
Trump had coveted and in the middle of
it he forced Secret Service to drive him
around in his in his SUV so he could
wave to people this is on China like
nobody ever thought possible my first
week in office I withdrew from the
terrible trans-pacific partnership which
would have been the death blow a death
knell for the U.S Auto industry Auto
people called me they said please don't
let that happen sir and I immediately
killed it
appreciated
Korea trade dealer disaster made it a
very good deal and saved our Auto
Workers from unfair foreign competition
I ended the horrible probably the worst
trade deal ever made by any country
NAFTA disaster
and replace it with the Brand New usmca
Mexico replaced it with the almost
identical but differently named usmca
Auto Workers and workers
and you know now they're trying to
renegotiate the deal Mexico and Canada
want to renegotiate the deal
because it's no good for them which
makes me feel good frankly
and they shouldn't do it he says get rid
of Trudeau
laughs
no
he treated us very nicely because he
signed the deal I didn't think I'd get
them to sign it but it's gone from the
worst deal made to the best deal made
and everyone said that couldn't be done
you know we had to get it through
Congress everyone said it couldn't be
done and Mexico and Canada have a lot of
a lot of juice in Congress I hate to
tell you that but we got it done and
it's a great deal and I hope Biden
doesn't renegotiate that like he's doing
with the Iran nuclear deal which is a
disaster
I stood up for China's abuses like no
president in history charging China we
charge China hundreds of billions of
dollars in taxes and tariffs which saved
our steal and it saved our Auto industry
among others and no president has ever
charged China not 10 cents not 10 cents
they never got charged they would
remember China doesn't pay the tariffs
the American companies importing the
stuff pay the tariffs you guys I know
know that means it's so big and in my
opinion not sustainable and I was all
set to bring it down to even and then we
had some bad news some strange votes
came in late at night three o'clock in
the morning strange things happened I
also authorized millions of dollars to
save and rebuild
Michigan's vital Soo locks and got you
hundreds of millions of dollars for
Great Lakes restoration initiative which
is a big deal hundreds of Millions
they've been trying to get that money
for many years the Democrats wouldn't
give it I got it
and they're doing great work too I
understand including on the locks those
locks were falling apart those locks
were not locks you think Trump has any
idea what he's talking about right now
at 7
risk everything that we fought to build
to build a thousand two hundred dollars
this year a giant tax on the American
workers that's bigger than any tax
increase that you could have and they
want to raise your taxes
real wages are falling and we are
teetering on the edge of an economy
Trump seems like the type of adult who
never grows out of not eating fish and
you don't want to know that's
simultaneous inflation and recession how
does that sound good it's not good and
this week Biden released a budget with
plans to Turbo Charge This Disaster with
record high spending the largest tax
increase in history and a business tax
hike that will export millions of jobs
back to China and other foreign
countries and guarantee that companies
will leave the United States in record
numbers to go elsewhere you know they
were all coming back under me I gave
them tremendous incentives to come back
I also gave them they had trillions of
dollars six trillion dollars outside of
the United States they couldn't get it
back in because of Regulation and
because of the ridiculous tax and I got
it back in they came back in and we
simplified the regulations and we
lowered the tax that they brought the
money back in
and they spent the money building in the
United States these are the things we
did these are just a small portion of
the things we did even right to try
we're going to a different subject right
to try where people that were terminally
ill would travel the world if they had
money if they didn't have money they'd
literally go home and die they'd go home
and die we have the greatest scientists
in the world we have the greatest labs
in the world and we have medicines that
are good but they won't be approved for
five years I took it down from 12 Years
down to five and I was going to get it a
lot lower than that but they had to wait
for years to get it approved by the I
like the people nodding about this part
where it's completely incoherent it's
the word salad and there's people
nodding like it makes sense it is
somebody was terminally ill or very ill
and they could prove that they got the
right to use this brand new beautiful
medicine that won't be approved for
another period of time and thousands and
thousands of lives are being saved all
over the country
just another thing that we did
another thing that we did
thousands of Lies Trump's great on
medications and stuff you know and then
I see the disinfectant is there a way we
can do something like that
by injection you will have liability I
said that's okay they'll sign a document
saying we're not going to hold the
country liable the company will have
liability that's okay we'll sign that
the company won't have any liability
they say the Pharmaceuticals companies
don't want because the people are
terminally ill that means they're very
far down the line and they don't want it
on their record they want to show that
this product works I said that's okay
we'll have a separate list so that it
won't affect them they said well that's
very good that's all very good and we
got it done thousands and thousands of
lives of these
but with respect to our country do not
lose hope because with the right
leadership America will be back greater
stronger and more powerful I hope he's
going into the conclusion now
one of the first things we will do when
Republicans retake Congress and it could
be big let's not talk about it
it could be big I heard today 68 seats
but I don't want to say that because if
it's 67 they'll say Trump suffered a
humiliating defeat
now I heard numbers from 20 to 68 68 so
far the highest every week it seems to
get higher all of these democrat
congress people are retiring because
they're getting their asses kicked in
every poll because they're so
incompetent
but we're going to retake Congress
bring Joe Biden and crazy Nancy Pelosi's
socialist spending spree to a screeching
halt our country can't take it any
longer the World Hears Pelosi and Biden
called Communists and socialists and
they just laugh they're like Americans
can't possibly be this stupid can they
and nobody body suffered like Michigan
nobody suffered stronger than what she
did to Michigan I don't believe I don't
even think New York suffered like you
did Gee everybody but her husband had to
stay and he could go ice skating he
could do whatever Ellie
who is the husband man that guy had a
hell of a life while you were locked
inside your homes
you weren't allowed to go out and cut
your grass you couldn't paint the
outside of your house
you're not getting was there ever a
point at which someone was not allowed
to cut their grass during covet in
Michigan I've never even heard that is
is there anything behind that can can
anyone fact check that
you must be a handsome son of a [ __ ] to
get away with it
no one ever
mentions that despite crushing our
citizens
citizen restrictions Biden presided over
more coveted deaths in 2021 than we had
in all of 2020. think of that with all
of the things that we did and all of the
Therapeutics all of the great things we
did more deaths Biden in your Governor
Gretchen Whitmer imposed rules on you
that they did not abide by themselves in
fact if you take a look around and look
at her friendships and look at her
people not only her husband they took
advantage of her and they took advantage
of you they totally failed
on the pandemic and now they are trying
to walk away from covid like nothing
happened this guy looks super bored
right here at one point he looked almost
like he was dozing this is November
they're already socket they I hear they
said there's another Strain coming in
we're gonna have to lock everybody up
everybody gets locked up
they like that gives them power gives
them power we will never forget what
they did to our children and to your
children we will never forget you look
at the difference with Republican run
States take a look at the difference
like day and night and that includes
also crime it's like day and night the
crime and democrat-run cities and states
it's never nobody's ever seen anything
like it I was given great praise for all
we did on operation warp speed we did a
great job with regard to Therapeutics
and everything else so much else from
making ventilators and making masks and
making everything wait operation warp
speed was vaccines Christmas stand up
for parental rights it's about time
right is he not mentioning the vaccines
parental rights
as president I was proud to issue the
world's first ban on critical race
Theory
Joe Biden meaningless immediately
but when we retake Congress Republicans
must ban critical race theory in our
schools ban it in our military and
bandited every part of our federal state
and local governments
furthermore America's moms and dads must
be given a veto over anyone teaching far
left gender theories to their children
without parental consent veto gender
theories that's new
[Applause]
it's unbelievable
this week the Biden Administration
released guidance endorsing hormone
therapy
puberty blockers
and sex-changing surgeries for children
and minor years well this guy's
literally yawning a child
and they said why the hell did you do
that to me mom or dad or government or
government
Biden's department of justice has also
announced they will punish medical
doctors who refuse to perform
irreversible my gender theory is Trump's
not nearly as manly as he believes
himself to be by whatever definition you
want to apply to that hell would have
ever believed we'd even be talking about
this stuff right
who would believe it with their
extremist sex and gender ideology the
Democrat Party is Waging War on reality
war on science war on children war on
women
the Republican party is now
the party of American women and American
[Music]
and we will protect women in sports
women in sports and not allow men to
enter into the women's game
thank you
you know I say it all the time those
people their seat is not as good as
yours but they're all famous
and some will go to Hollywood someday
there's a producer out there watching
and you have plenty of conservative
producers in Hollywood they just don't
like to talk about it who do you vote
for well I didn't vote for Trump then
they get in there I'm going to vote for
that Trump Trump trump
I like paying low taxes I like having
good military good education low
regulation
then they come out that's a very common
working class feeling when you're
getting squeezed and you can't afford
housing and things are expensive and you
haven't gotten a raise and college costs
80 grand a year
and you go I feel so good that the
military keeps buying missiles to store
in Germany and all these stuff it's just
such a great feeling damn business who
you they never had it was like 40 50
percent of the people said that and then
some would say crooked Hillary Clinton
and some would say Trump right this was
on the 16 election where we didn't do
nearly as well as the 20 but these are
Minor Details but they'd say Clinton and
so I got a call at five o'clock in the
afternoon I saw what we did so well sir
I have some pretty bad news it's looking
really bad a lot of people are saying
the exit vote you know it's an exit for
where these drugs back there they ask
the people
they say
who did you vote for
and everybody said that uh she was going
to lead and she was leading big
but one person then called and it was
sad I actually went to our great first
lady who everybody loves our first lady
and I said ma'am
she was a great first lady
elegant woman and she loves you but they
I went to our first lady I said darling
you know the athletes I left it all in
the field I did I came back from
Michigan by the way
I think Grand Rapids right Grand Rapids
I I arrived at four o'clock in the
morning we made we had a great time in
great the place was packed with 34 000
people standing outside of that
Amphitheater type place but I went to
the first lady I said it looks bad looks
really bad but I don't feel bad because
I left it all out in the field I was
doing five and six major rallies a day
for a week who the hell could do that
who could do that nobody could do that
nobody
Biden couldn't do that is this
considered a cabaret what Trump's doing
oh a sentence
and if I would have made one mistake
if there was one mispronunciation of a
complex word
they would have said Trump is losing it
with Biden they say oh it's okay
but it's true I did I did five I did one
day where I did six he's a big rallies
too these are with 30 40 50 000 people
like Stephanie cepha Hyde would land
that beautiful plane and would just get
off the plane do a rally at the airport
I didn't have to travel but we did a lot
and it was looking good it was feeling
good the spirit was unbelievable and
then I got this call sir it's not
looking good I'm telling you he wanted
to be nice this person to call a good
person he wanted to I said give it to me
it's not looking good sir I said why
because the exit voting is looking
really sure and they started going on
television and the you know these
Geniuses on television right these
people that are so bad sleepy eyes
checked uh the whole group
now even this story like Trump won in
2016 but this story is a Lie by 720 the
first results came in at 7 pm Eastern
back in November of 2016. by 7 25 that
go go to my stream by 7 25 I was saying
it's kind of looking like Trump's gonna
win 25 minutes after the first results
there was no long period where it looked
like Hillary was winning on that night
you're doing unbelievable in North
Carolina
you're going to win Florida big we did
it a second time
I think they spent 300 million dollars
against me in Florida I never saw so
many negative ads right and I spent
about three and a half dollars and we
crushed them
that's because the election was honest
we crushed them here too I hate to tell
you we crushed a beer we crushed them
here too
and where is bishan is she here where's
Misha
where is you stand up
we crushed them me Sean Maddox
who's in charge of a lot of different
things and a good person with her
husband who's going to be the boss very
soon
congratulations thank you for everything
but we crushed him probably time to rap
but anyway so they came out they came
out and they said sir it's looking bad
this one guy called up he said no sure
there's never been a time where so many
people didn't respond or responded with
the f word to these people because they
ate them The Passion of the hatred of
the media so they'd use terrible
language in some cases and in some cases
they just said I don't want to say and
he said we consider almost all of those
people As Trump voters you're gonna
you're gonna win big and we won big he
was right so I went to the first lady I
said I don't think we're going to make
it darling but you know what I left it
on the field
if you don't make it and it's fair and
square that's acceptable that's okay but
if you win in a landslide and they steal
it and rig it it's no good it's not
acceptable it's no good
be a lot easier for me to say oh be a
lot easier for me to do like many people
have done get up and just say
congratulations uh
whoever it is I'm running against I mean
if you're running I'd say
congratulations Joe now watch if I say
it I don't want to say it because
they'll put it on like crowds falling
asleep
remember the Russia if you're listening
thing so they cut it off immediately
because it was a joke Russia if you're
listening to do this or that with her
emails or whatever the hell I want
and then I laughed they left the whole
place was left but they cut it off
immediately said Russia if you're
listening cut
I have not seen it cut there even once
so this guy calls up and he said you
know what you know what
I think you're going to win you're going
to win Florida definitely you're going
to win North Carolina you're going to
win Pennsylvania you're going to win
Michigan we think
we think
and so I went back to the first lady I
said uh forget what I told you an hour
ago
it's looking slightly better no this
guy's attitude was anybody that says
we're not going to tell you he
considered that a vote
so that was different interesting people
they don't consider it he did he said
you know what I think that's a vote for
Trump and he said you're going to win so
I was quite happy and then in the
evening we did win and we won big we won
big and we're one big in Michigan
we won big in your side and I think we
did a hell of a job we saved your Auto
industry we we saved your steel industry
we saved a lot of things he's talking
about two elections ago and he's
spending a lot of time on it CEOs who
get rich off the world's worst human
rights abusers abroad while they push
radical politics into our classrooms
here and at home giant corporations that
do business in communist China while
they attack our values here in America
should face a massive crushing tax on
all profits coming out of China and I
was getting ready to do that
they should lose all tax breaks and all
preferential treatment under U.S law the
American people will not sit idly by and
allow our children to be indoctrinated
segregated and mutilated by The Lunatic
language
[Music]
we're not going to stand for it
the crowd's back
another key step for a republican
Congress will be to restore free speech
in America oh
you know I didn't know we lost it in
Russia the people in Russia don't even
know they're having a war because they
have a rigged press we have the same rig
press maybe not quite as severe but
it'll be there in the not too distant
future what both the New York Times And
The Washington Post have now finally
admitted that Hunter Biden's laptop the
laptop from hell
Israel which I think it's really a
laptop it's not a floodlight with that
name first I think so I never get credit
for fake news I never get credit for the
laptop from hell I never get credit for
crooked Hillary we had so many great
names I won't go into the Republican
names because I like them all now
but we he goes we start we don't want to
do that I'm actually getting along with
the very wide rather than that but we
came up with some pretty good names but
this is the laptop from hell and
pollsters say that we would have brought
an additional 17 points to our already
record-setting election you know
what I want more votes than any sitting
president in history by many millions
but lost to Biden by 8 million
we were told that if you got the same
thing as last time 63 by John McLaughlin
great pollster Towery great pollster sir
if you get 63 million again
you win in a landslide sure we got
almost 75 million votes that we didn't
win
something wrong there you're lost you
ever see The Bookies in Vegas as smart
Vegas bookies and London bookies
it's like starting at around 50 50 and
then 60 40. then it's 70 30. going up up
up up is going then we're almost at a
hundred percent
and they called off the bets it was over
and then they say wait a minute
something's going on over here
and some of them many of them wouldn't
take any more bets they said something's
wrong here because they thought the
election was over so did I about 10 of
the London bookies were sure of it say
almost all of the people in this room
said this election is over we did a
great job together
but you know there's an expression
sometimes the vote counter is far more
important than the candidate and we
can't let that ever happen again and we
have to get to the is that Stalin who
said that or is that misattributed to
Stalin that quote rings a bell but I
thought it was like an authoritarian nut
who said it
Matt Christina good luck
it's an easy one
Detroit is going to be easy
Detroit will be very easy for them
they're going to look at Detroit you
don't even have to go any further
we're just seven months away from the
most important midterm victory in
American history and we need a landslide
so big that the radical left cannot rig
it or steal it you know at a certain
point like in Florida like in Texas
remember they said Texas is in play you
know what that means it's going to be
close I said wait a minute
what they're trying to do is rig it
because it's going to be close I said
how is it close I'm for oil I'm for God
I'm for guns Second Amendment
they want no oil
how does this play in Texas
they want no oil
they want no God and they want no guns
how does that play no guns no oil no God
in Texas and then they say it's going to
be close it wasn't close we knocked the
hell out of it was pretty close
but we have to win big because there's a
certain point at which they can't cheat
anymore
it reaches a certain point we actually I
believe they substantially went over and
so it's funny Trump says it wasn't close
Biden got 46.5 percent
in uh Texas
that's the most the Democrats gotten
since 1976 and Trump just feeds this
dribble to the crowd no Democrat has
gotten as much of the Texas vote
as Biden got in 2020 dating back to 1976
and Trump's like no we crushed him
actually it was the smallest margin
dating back to 76. yeah we're going to
take back the house we're going to take
back the Senate and we're going to take
back America
oh this is the uh conclusion and in 2024
most importantly
we are going to take back
[Music]
when the Republican Congress we will
fight for more jobs for Michigan
families fair trade for Michigan workers
and more Michigan factories forging more
products stamped with that beautiful
phrase made in the USA
that's a beautiful I don't know if you
guys saw but at some Mar-A-Lago event
with gay Trump supporters in the last
couple of days Trump said to them you
don't look gay it's it's a surreal
moment I keep them in Mexico they said
no way I said that's okay we're gonna
tax every damn car you send into our
country they said like we said we'd love
to keep them in Mexico
we're going to reimpose title 42 which
just today they ended basically that
says they can't come into our country
that means they're all going to come
into our country at a level that you
haven't seen yet title 42 is my deal
add to and strengthen border patrol and
ice and law enforcement yeah it reminds
me of when people say to me you don't
look Hispanic like they're saying it is
a good thing like don't don't worry I
never would have guessed you were
Hispanic from looking at you I'm like oh
thank you wow well finish it could be
done in a few weeks finish the wall the
wall is almost complete that's one of
the reasons we had such good numbers
took us two and a half years of
litigation over 11 lawsuits so we won
them all we want them all you know we
appointed over 300 judges can you
imagine that three Supreme Court
Justices one and a half so remember
earlier Trump said we built 500 miles of
wall now he said the Wall's almost done
but the wall would have to be the border
is 2 000 miles so he earlier admitted
that it's nowhere near done but now he
says it's almost done China accountable
for unleashing the virus have to do it
have to do it there are ways to do it
we will stop the Biden crime wave and
democrat-run cities we will give our
police officers as our 100 support and
respect
we will give them back their power to do
the job like only they are capable of
doing and we will restore law and
ordered America and in particular in our
out of control democrat-run cities and
states we will do it whether they like
it or not because it's at a point look
the one good thing about the
catastrophic election result is that
people see how bad they are if I had one
and everything was honest legit and I
just kept running we would have
continued to go through all this stuff
about all these wonderful things now
they've had a chance to destroy our
country in four years so when we go back
if we go back if it's me you got a lot
of
he got some good candidates and you have
some bad candidates but you know what
if I do make you happy if I do make you
happy would anybody here like to see me
run
[Music]
so this is probably how it starts years
of trump asking do you want me to run
so if we do it we'll do it just uh we
can do things the right way and we'll be
able to do it and nobody will be able to
criticize us because nobody has ever run
a country worse in our history and in
most other countries history then the
United States of America has been run
for the last 15 months so we'll be able
to do it right and we're going to bring
back Law and Order we will protect
innocent life we will now remember Law
and Order doesn't mean due process
earlier they were chanting lock up
Hillary Hillary's not been charged nor
tried nor convicted so for them Law and
Order doesn't mean due process don't
don't confuse that of our nation's
founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our great
beautiful American flag
so in conclusion
of our country in conclusion I'm the
most important American in history and
will not even challenge that statement
because there's never been anything like
this movement and the fake news media
back there never challenges that I say
it all the time this is the greatest
because they can
this is the greatest movement you
elected a president twice and we're
going to possibly have to do it a third
time
together we're standing up against some
of the most Sinister forces entrenched
interests and vicious opponents our
people have ever seen or our country has
ever seen despite all your hearing and
seeing of China and Russia and Iran and
others our biggest danger is not from
outside coming in our biggest danger is
from the sick and radical politicians
that are knowingly or unknowingly
wanting to destroy our country it's the
biggest danger it's a bigger danger than
Russia and China
but no matter how big or powerful these
corrupt radicals may be you must never
forget this nation does not belong to
them this nation belongs to you the
people that built it
this is your home this is your heritage
and our American Liberty is your
god-given right God given
from Midland to Mackinac from Lansing to
Grand Rapids and from Battle Creek I
love that cereal
to right here in Washington Township we
inherit the legacy of Michigan Patriots
who gave their blood sweated tears for
this beloved Nation
this is the state where Henry Ford
invented the assembly line that's not
bad
Henry Ford sadly was a disgusting
anti-semite Cal log
revolutionized entire Industries and
Michigan is the state that gave us
Motown a Mustang
and rivaled might you gave us the Rival
the might of the Great American Midwest
that's big stuff
it was hard-working Patriots like you
who built this country and together we
are going to save our country we can't
let this happen
we are going to fight for America like
no one has ever fought before we will
not let radical left lunatics or rhinos
who are unwilling to fight because
they're weak and they're very stupid
take away from us what has been so
brilliantly built for nearly 250 years
we will not let climate hoaxsters and
extremists use the sanctity of our
climate to destroy our country what a
sanctity of climate mean I've never even
heard that term before the sanctity of
the climate talk complain cajole and
laugh at the stupidity of America and
its politicians
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no Summit we cannot reach there
is no challenge we cannot meet there is
no Victory we cannot have we will not
Bend we will not break we will not yield
we will never give in we will never give
up we will never ever back down as long
as we are confident and United
all right
the terrible and very sick people that
we are fighting
do not stand a chance of Victory because
we are Americans you built this country
you built this country and Americans
kneel to God and God Alone
my fellow citizens this perhaps a deeply
spiritual guy you can tell has only just
begun you know it's only just begun
and it's time to start thinking about
greatness for our country again we don't
talk about growing our country anymore
we don't talk about all of those things
that really go to making a country great
like we used to many many years ago
decades ago
all we talk about today is race
inflation and the environment talk about
nothing else we don't talk about what it
takes to make our country great again
and we always have to remember
that we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious American Nation
that's what we are we're a glorious
American Nation and you should be
so proud of it and so with the help of
everyone here today thank you Michigan
and citizens all across our land we will
make America powerful again
we will make America wealthy again we
will make
America strong again
we will make America proud again
we will make America this is such a dumb
gimmick he does at the end of every
speech it's so dumb he will make America
great again thank you Michigan God bless
you thank you thank you
[Music]
really quite an event
around
[Music]
an extremely corrosive 90 minutes for
American democracy showing us really the
bottom of the barrel of political
discourse
um he told many lies and the crowd liked
them and very surreal I mean really the
world laughs whenever I cover these
things two things happen in my email oh
thanks to everybody thank you all these
people gifting all these subscriptions
thank you two things happen in my email
Trump supporters who were just looking
for the rally are really mad at me they
really don't like me so I get emails
from them
oh my God look at this guy what a
buffoon and then the other thing is
people from other countries write in and
they say what the hell is wrong in the
United States David what the hell is
wrong in the United States those are the
two major
responses to covering these events
pointing at people
look at this I mean it is humiliating
look at this guy
[Music]
why don't you hear it
anyway it's all pretty depressing it's
all pretty depressing
um
and you know it's not clear if lead
paint chips are to blame or some kind of
strange
uh anyway let's not speculate let's not
speculate but it's it's uh it's a very
scary scary time for the the United
States of America folks that's going to
do it for me we have a big big week
ahead of us a big week of shows we've
got some travel I'm going to be coming
to you from some very interesting
locations and uh so many different
things so thank you to every single one
of you the crowd now will be glad you're
not there it's going to be hours before
they're allowed to leave but fortunately
we can just click over to something else
um thank you to everybody who joined me
thank you to our moderators thank you to
every single twitch Prime subscriber
viewer troll we banned about 50 people
during this stream and of course
everybody oh hold on let's listen to
what's going on here real quick from
hell I walked around our viewers are mad
they want Justice they want some type of
oh sorry this was earlier I'll cover
this Monday all right we'll see
everybody later thank you for being here
thank you for the support we'll see you
all very soon